Dave Chappelle's new comedy special is
pretty good I think it uh wasn't as good
as sticks and stones of course the
critics are outraged saying it was just
bad I love how this new generation of
woke media critic hates everything that
most people likes whatever but of course
you see it Rotten Tomatoes The Audience
absolutely loved it but it's generating
a lot of controversy which is a stupid
thing to say because it's just a fringe
group of woke weirdos however it's still
a lot of people at Netflix first we
heard a trans woman stormed into a
meeting and started yelling then we
heard someone at Netflix leaked
information about how much Dave
Chappelle got paid now we're hearing 1
000 woke employees are planning a
virtual shutdown where they will not be
working Netflix has even fired the
leaker and claimed we are on the right
side of History which is kind of odd
considering cuties but sure try and
stand on that Hill Netflix I don't think
anyone is going to be defending you for
the most part but I think most of us
like Dave Chappelle and this just goes
to show I think you know
kind of optimism here kind of being
optimistic because it doesn't look like
their protests are going to work Netflix
doesn't care they make too much money
off this people like Dave Chappelle so
we got a lot to talk about we got we got
to talk about this we got to talk about
the economic collapse the the holidays
are on the verge of well the holidays
will happen I don't say they won't
happen but pumpkin shortages turkey
shortages Christmas tree shortages well
you name it that's all thanks to Joe
Biden but don't worry gen SEC he says
this is good news it means people are
buying stuff yeah right okay joining us
to talk about a lot of these topics and
probably a whole bunch of comic book
stuff is nerd Roddick
hi how you doing I'm great you want to
introduce yourself yes my name is Gary
bickler I come to uh from nerdroduct.com
and nerd Roddick here on YouTube it's my
first time here happy to be here
happy to talk to everybody it's uh
impressive as uh
oppressive the compound I like our new
studio yeah I I love the new studio love
the house love everything about it and
happy to be here it's an honor howdy my
name is lucidowski here of we are
change.org and first off uh it looks
like Instagram I might be wrong took off
a warning before people followed me on
my Instagram page so thank you guys for
uh helping me Rectify that situation by
having hundreds of people follow my
account second off I personally want to
thank YouTube for demonetizing my
channel a few years ago because if it
wasn't for that I wouldn't have an
awesome t-shirt store and shirts like
this that I'm wearing right now that say
I'm Joe Biden and I forgot this message
which you could exclusively get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com so thank you
YouTube and Instagram never thought I
would say that um you also have a
crystal around your neck what is that
quartz
um this was a gift I forgot exactly what
it was it's not it's not a course it's
something else I forgot um this is my
favorite comic book of all time I'm glad
you're here Gary this is The Infinity
Gauntlet number four it's epic this is
when Comics were real and tell me off
the bat what we're gonna say what's your
favorite comic oh what's my favorite if
I have a single favorite comic it's a
run so it's uh Daredevil Frank Miller's
Daredevil right really wow yeah I
thought though I read that I was 12. it
was epic uh the first time that I saw
they had killed somebody before but
first time I had read a character get
killed yeah that's something about that
and there was something that impressed a
lot of us 12 year olds back then who are
very impressionable but Frank Miller's
art and his writing was just Next Level
good wow maybe that was brilliant yeah
this series is great well I'm Ian
Crossland happy to be here thanks and I
am also showing off Luke's merch from
the what is it called what's your site
thebestpoliticalshirts.com that's right
and he gave this to me for Christmas and
now I have it it looks way better on me
than it is on him more I'm gonna do the
Christmas shopping now because of the
shortages so let me know what you guys
like yeah awesome I'm also here pushing
buttons recorder getting better at my
job again and uh yeah sponsor the
economy is on fire but don't fret my
friends you can still get all of your
essential all vitamins and minerals well
I don't know about all of them but you
can get Eternal Reds by going to
drinkrightfeelwell.com this is
biotrust's blend of eight super fruits
beets and berries you mix into your
drink and it's exactly what I have done
because it tastes really really good
it's it's actually really good I would I
would say it's like it's like Flavor a
you know whatever those things are you
mix them in but it's only it's it's
healthy so it comes with 250 milligrams
of Vitamin C if you're not getting you
know your vitamins minerals or your
vegetables and you know your leafy
greens or whatever you can definitely do
something like this to try and
supplement and it makes your drinks
taste delicious head over to
drinkrightfieldwell.com you'll get 51
off of BioTrust Eternal Reds today and
they say you'll get a 60-day money-back
guarantee free shipping on every order
over fifty dollars in gifts with every
order that wow for every order today bio
trust don't it's a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of six million
meals this year you'll get free VIP la
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free new e-report the top 11
foods that boost circulation now one of
the things I really like about this is
that the vitamin C is in it and I
realize you know especially I'm doing
more uh I'm not eating a lot of sugar or
breads or fruits I'm eating more
vegetables and meats and that means I'm
not getting as much vitamin C as I used
to so that's why I've been taking this
off especially But ultimately I'll just
say this when we got the sample it
tasted so good we made this awesome
drink with it I was like yo can we get a
bunch of this stuff we'll definitely do
a shout out for this because this is
like a healthy way to make a delicious
drink I'll tell you that so go to
drinkrightfieldwell.com special shout
out BioTrust thanks for being a sponsor
of the show go to timcast.com become a
member we have a new show which
hopefully is launching today the Green
Room so we have a bunch of a bunch of
footage and shows from when guests have
shown up and hanging out in the green
room playing pool talking about weird
stuff time travel just kind of
nonsensical things more fun and
apolitical stuff from some of your most
famous from from some of your most
favorite political people and they'll
start going up on Fridays so definitely
become a member don't forget to like
this video subscribe to subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends and now let's get into that
first big story Dave Chappelle we got
this story from Gizmodo and there's a
lot of there's a lot of moving Parts
here 1 000 Netflix employees are
reportedly planning a walkout to protest
new Chappelle special staffers are
threatening to revolt after Executives
doubled down on claims that content on
screen doesn't directly translate to
real world harm all right I'm I'm I'm
well I'm in a tough spot right here guys
okay Netflix they did cuties that was
messed up they also do big mouth I also
think that's pretty messed up yes but
they're defending Dave Chappelle from a
woke mob what do we do
conflicted take it one situation at a
time I guess I I I'm not subscribed to
Netflix anymore but I support them in
supporting Dave Chappelle uh and it
we're starting to see certain little
certain things break down in our system
as time goes and having uh this is gonna
be a a huge Face-Off between two groups
we'll just say it's important I mean no
one's perfect if someone does good you
compliment them if something if someone
does something bad you criticize them
there's a lot of things to criticize
Netflix especially with its founder
especially with its history especially
with its ha it's past and the
psychological symbolism and a lot of its
content but when we look at the Dave
Chappelle special you know unless you
watched it I don't think you should be
commenting on it because I just finished
watching it today and it's not his best
work but it's it's powerful it's
impactful because it I don't want to
ruin this so spoiler alert if you
haven't watched it yet you might want to
just mute it for like two minutes while
I talk here I mean there's a story at
the end that revolves around Daphne
Dorman a friend of Dave Chappelle that
according to her family committed
suicide because the woke mob went after
her because she supported Dave Chappelle
this is a trans woman that Dave
Chappelle was friends with was doing
comedy shows with was helping supporting
and treating like a student of the art
and Daphne tweeted I tweeted this on my
official Twitter account uh look we are
changed because I I I I I sent out the
tweet that got her attacked by the hate
mob and it's an important one to note
here to see what she tweeted here
because the family members are literally
saying it was this hate mob that led to
her committing suicide recently when she
defended Dave Chappelle's Sticks and
Stones uh Netflix special and she said
quote punching down requires you to
consider yourself Superior to another
group Dave Chappelle doesn't consider
himself better than me in any way he
isn't punching up or punching down he's
punching lines that's his job and he's a
master of his craft and that's what
that's what she wrote and this is what
uh um I mean it's a partial spoiler but
in the special I mean a large portion of
his is dedicated to this story with a
series of jokes in it and he has this
line where he's like man I don't know
what they said to her but they drove her
to climb up on top of building and jump
off and and then he tells a joke about
it and and then you know everyone laughs
and he says Daphne would have loved that
joke because she was part of my tribe a
comedian and see that that's the thing
right this is an individual a trans
woman who was like yes people can do
jokes it can be offensive it's like it
is what it is Dave Chappelle we totally
get it but this woke mob
they need to control
comedy art laughter
you know I mean maybe it's cliche to say
communist right that's what the Soviets
did that they can't allow people to have
free thought that would Challenge and
and spread so they specifically Target
it now these people are planning on
protesting I think it shows man their
their their their their power is waning
now now let me just say about about
Netflix
they did cuties man that's messed up
they do big mouth you guys know what big
mouth is yeah no that's Nick Kroll big
mouth is a show about uh Cartoon like
pre like children going through puberty
and it's extremely sexually explicit and
I'm just like yo it's a cartoon it's not
the same as cuties but it's still like
weird like what they're doing like I
don't know man I saw some people okay
you should watch it and I'm like I guess
I was at this guy's house and they put
it on and I'm like dude this is what are
you watching man like I don't want I
can't even say what some of these
episodes are about because YouTube would
would literally like demonetize or
de-rank or even ban us if I gave you the
synopsis of one one episode I saw yeah
we'd probably get taken down like you
can't even talk about it but it's on
Netflix Netflix is also the company that
fired one of their I think an executive
got fired because he was explaining to
staff what words were offensive and
should not be said and in doing so he
said the words and so they freaked out
and they fired the guy
now
with Netflix coming out and defending
Dave Chappelle this is what we got we
have to defend them on this one because
all the people who came out and said
Netflix is evil oh I'm canceling my
subscription should be coming back and
say for this I actually will consider
subscribing because think about it even
though they did bad things if there's no
Redemption for Netflix they won't change
course if Netflix feels like look we
tried you know giving these people what
they wanted with Dave Chappelle it
wasn't enough screw it cut them off
there's no point we're never going to
win them back if we say this is what we
do like and we're willing to sign up now
because you're defending Dave Chappelle
they're gonna be like hey do more of
this the woke people aren't buying
anything they don't got money these are
the people that we should be supporting
that's why I think it's important to
actually be like
defend Netflix on this one yeah I mean
it you know we don't have to always lump
everything in when talking about a
particular case and again Case by case
basis there's a lot to criticize Netflix
I mean it's just weird that the founder
of Netflix his uncle was Edward Bernays
he's a nephew of Sigmund Freud that's
like that yeah yeah this is according to
the New York Times and they're reporting
on him so you know this is obviously an
industry that has grown very fast very
rapidly and I still think it's figuring
itself out because you do see a lot of
propaganda you do see a lot of
subliminal messaging you do see a lot of
crazy uh content out there that you
don't see on normal television you do
see them taking risks especially with
things like black mirror there's a lot
of predictive programming there's a lot
of conditioning there's a lot of things
that we could say here but I I still
think by and large Netflix has expanded
it's it's it's it's at a point where
YouTube is trying to become it so that's
that's power right there to say the
least how they're gonna wield this power
how are they going to move forward it's
going to be very interesting to see but
there are there are major Powerhouse to
contend with it it is it is difficult
though I mean because they still don't
they still have cuties up yeah and it's
like even if you defend Dave Chappelle
they're also getting you to come on
board with that kind of garbage yeah so
I'll I've support them defending sorry I
support them defending Dave Chappelle
all day long I'm not going to sign up
again until they get rid of cuties I
kind of Hold the Line there and it's
hard you're right we need to show people
support when they you know like a good
if they're a puppy dog you go good dog
when they do something good they pee on
the floor you get mad at them but uh
let's see what they do in this one
instance and then I will see if I can
support it later it's a weird fight
because Dave Chappelle isn't against
trans people he has friends that are
trans people he cares about the
community his message is like hey stop
stop trying to tell me how to live my
life stop trying to control every aspect
of my existence stop trying to cancel
people just for trying to make you laugh
and I think that's the bigger takeaway
here because you know this is all at the
end of the day a coming to comedy coming
to someone mastering an art trying to
help people trying to make people's
lives better trying to improve the
quality of their mental health by being
able to laugh at very tough difficult
situations which sadly are stigmatized
to a point in level where you can't even
discuss them honestly on you know the
major information highways that we have
on the internet you you can't really get
the truth about a lot of these issues
you can't really speak about them openly
so the last thing that we have is comedy
so to see this kind of war against
comedy it's troubling I have a lot of
negative things to say about Netflix on
this side it's a weird fight because
it's it's it's weird leftists who are
protesting someone trying to help them
and make them laugh who's essentially on
their side in many elements of his
existence you know it used to be the
left used to protest multinational
corporations governments the military
industrial complex the prison industrial
complex big Pharma that's the old one
there's a lot of dust to wipe off there
Tucker Carlson critical of the World
Trade Organization or something you know
he's talking about that and I'm just
like man to see Tucker Carlson on the
side of the WTF protesters from the
battle in Seattle it's just a weird
thing it really is man but hey I'll take
it you know we're in yeah we're in a
weird timeline for sure I think I mean
there's that I want to sit back and kind
of watch them eat each other at some
point times like this it's just it's fun
because they deserve it but um what what
you said earlier date if you watch the
special yeah there's no way you can
criticize it without watching it because
it really is an end to all his Netflix
specials uh it really is kind of uh an
epilogue to Sticks and Stones which is
absolutely just epic it's so good uh and
he really says what he means and it's
like what I was noticing was he says
really normal stuff that's uh that's
considered are controversial now to
where I I don't even I mean I'm a guest
on a show so I don't want to repeat it
but he said something very normal about
women in the process of giving birth and
uh what that is uh you know compared to
and people were applauding and we're
like yeah that's something that like
really happens every day it's not yeah
it's weird that we're applauding stuff
like that he's like women give birth
yeah
dude you know uh I talk to a lot of
regular people
you know I go out we go to the mall I
was at a farm recently talking to some
regular people just about life and their
opinions are fair as similar to uh to
all of ours I think the issue is that
these leftists and people at Netflix
it's that tweet we pulled up before for
Matthew Iglesias where he's like Twitter
is people who are 95 further left than
the average voter arguing that people
who are 75 percent further left in the
regular voter are far right or alt-right
or something that's exactly it Netflix
thinks Twitter is moderate
and that's like that's like going into a
sewer and thinking you're getting farm
fresh vegetables when it's black sludge
you're like literally pouring switching
to come like looks like farm fresh
vegetables to me it's like dude that is
that is the after effect of all of the
refuse and waste and chemicals
it's not real life
this is what you get these are the shows
they make it's kind of crazy to me that
they uh
that they make and and keep making some
of these shows and some some shows get
canceled I don't even know how they did
they determine which show is worth
keeping perhaps they liked cuties
because the controversy was just good
for their brand recognition or something
but a lot of people canceled their
membership after that I did a lot I mean
sure I made sure I canceled mine as well
uh and you know everyone has a friend of
a friend anyway to see some of the
latest stuff that's how I watched uh you
know today's uh Dave Chappelle special
but this is a very interesting uh
dichotomy because it used to be Netflix
used to allow you to rate uh the the
videos that you would watch out of five
stars and then of course came Amy
Schumer and uh absolutely nuked and
destroyed that system because people are
like no we don't like this we don't
support this and they didn't like that
and they got rid of the people's voice
on Netflix that was hilarious
problem now you have that um that Hannah
Hannah gadsby I think her name is Josh
yeah and she's complaining about it as
well because they're like look we have
an Eclectic group of voices check out
the story we got from The Hollywood
Reporter Netflix fires employee for
leaking confidential information on
Chappelle special the employee leaked
financial data to Bloomberg which
reported in October 13 October 13th
article that Netflix spent 24.1 million
dollars on Dave Chappelle's the closer
whoa
not only is Dave Chappelle smacking down
wokeness and just speaking his mind he's
getting paid that kind of money to do it
nice nice wow that was half of what he
walked away uh from Comedy Central for
so he's he's made it back I'm guessing
and good for Dave yeah well he also said
he's not going to speak about this again
he says it's over I'm not going to be
doing um specials I'm done it I gotta
say watching the special it feels like
they got him Dave Chappelle was like um
I can't do this anymore he said I'm not
gonna make these jokes anymore because
if they don't get it I don't know I
can't do it Dave Chappelle gave it
that's too bad because he's a cultural
force and he can change people's minds
he did it before he walked away from the
Chappelle show just went to Africa for a
while
it's checked out he does what he wants
yeah I think I think it was because
um I think his story was that when he
did the Chappelle show he did a sketch
that was critical of racism but the
people like he talked to someone who
didn't know that's what it was and it
kind of got him mad that he was like is
that what you think I'm trying to say I
remember reading a story about that I
don't know maybe it's been a long time
I'm getting the story wrong but
something like that here's where I think
it's really crazy
Netflix says we are on the right side of
history in Rao on internal Message Board
of the comedian's jokes that that to me
is is the crazy crazy thing he says
quote we let go a spokesperson said we
let go of an employee for sharing
confidential commercial extensive
information outside the company we
understand this employee may have been
motivated by disappointment and hurt
with Netflix but maintaining a culture
of trust and transparency is core to our
company the longtime employee was fired
because they leaked that information but
to say that they're on the right side of
History I do believe that our commitment
to artistic expression and pleasing our
members is the right long-term choice
for Netflix and that we are on the right
side but only time will tell is what he
said apparently what they said to the
New York Times this is what you get when
you uh let when you let this stuff go on
for too long and now it's biting them in
the ass so good uh in that part of it
I'm I'm extremely happy about to see
them suffer these consequences yeah I
mean that being said maybe not
supporting them is still the right move
maybe it
oh I don't support centralized
um entertainment networks like this I
think you need a decentralized network
that's going to have propagate the art
because anytime you have a gatekeeper
you're going to have people saying yes
or no and that's the problem it's not
that they said no it's saying giving
someone the ability to say yes or no and
get super rich off it well on that note
there are a lot of different options
that you have you can let the free
market decide where you're going to
spend your entertainment dollars I use
a choice I don't know if you completely
agree with them or whatever but you can
use Disney plus you can use Hulu you can
use like DirecTV and Amazon they're all
so oh I know they're all bad in
different ways Hulu did that tweet where
they were like remember a couple years
ago don't wear Halloween costumes that
are insensitive and I'm like why is why
why is my online streaming platform
telling you what to wear because you get
the central Authority that builds up
millions billions of followers and then
they sell the company to some idiot that
gets the that gets the Twitter account
and of 40 million people and can tell
you to do stupid stuff and now most of
these platforms are filled with ads
you're you're paying a premium just for
a specific uh Channel and now Amazon
Hulu all of them are like Paramount
They're all playing ads before you get
to watch the content that you paid for
like it's just another slap in the face
up to the consumer
and that's probably why they're not
doing that well and they're going to all
have to either they're one of them is
probably going to get bought up by uh
like Paramount it might be for sale by
Apple but sometimes and they're way too
late in the ad game but the reason
you know I I think Netflix is way too
powerful uh and they're a billion dollar
corporation that does make way you know
they were uh this is a rumor okay but
they were thinking about uh going into
content creation like YouTube they
thought about it seriously three years
ago ditched out of it yeah they it was
just two they were too far behind right
uh but their infrastructure I had a I
had a good friend who worked on worked
with them in the early days that
infrastructure that they worked on that
for years so they are light years ahead
of any other streaming service for a
long time uh they've have patents on
certain menus that's why you're on
Disney plus you're on Paramount plus
you're like why is this menu set well
they own half of it half most of the
menus and stuff they own the patents on
that so they can't go remember wasn't
Amazon gonna do a YouTube thing a few
years back remember that yeah well
they're doing some kind of live
streaming thing now which is weird no on
Amazon on the website they're doing like
here watch this live stream which is
like usually someone trying to you know
sell products that's pretty weird Amazon
live is that what that is yeah is this
the right side of history is the
question I don't think so centralized
authorities are not we're not going to
look back on having a gatekeeper as as
the right side it's gonna I guess I
looked at it like freedom of expression
not centralized Authority so I suspect
what's happening with Netflix is that
they're looking at Twitter and they're
looking at their marketing data and
they're like okay Twitter's really not
real life and what's going to be best
for us is actually having diverse
viewpoints and diverse opinions whether
everyone agrees with stuff like cuties
or whether everyone agrees with stuff
like Dave Chappelle or not which I think
is probably smart and will do them well
in the long term you know the challenges
uh
this is where our culture's at I mean
you've got Dave Chappelle The Closer on
Netflix it's a point of conversation
people people group around it and that
means people have to get a subscription
to be able to watch it or you know
borrow a friends but for the most part
it means more subscriptions and that's
exactly what Netflix wants
then they'll probably just keep doing
the same controversial stuff back and
forth generate more controversy which is
good for their business no matter what
happens
I agree I
I want I like Dave Chappelle I'm gonna
side with Dave Chappelle and not Netflix
and I think the only reason Netflix is
supporting Dave Chappelle is because
they gave him 24 million dollars and
it's just they're weighing out like what
you know because if they if they
they're just weighing what the backlash
is going to be what's going to be worse
and they're are they publicly they're
publicly traded too aren't they yes yeah
imagine explaining to the to your
shareholders why we dump 24 million pull
it within like a week or something all
right it's been a little bit longer than
that but still
uh yeah I
having a thousand if I think if a
thousand employees do walk out that
might make a difference I mean there's a
lot of people there I don't know if that
is actually going to happen I mean I
mean who's saying that like where's the
claim coming from there's going to be a
thousands of people coming out on
protest I mean maybe insiders I mean
yeah I mean that just seems extremely
optimistic you could you could never ask
protesters how many people are out of
protest because they're they're always
going to uh exaggerate the number and
it's just ridiculous to think that's
going to happen but but have any of
these people watched the show because I
think if they do they would get a sense
of understanding and about that though I
know of course it's not you go to these
people and you're like here's the video
clip of what he actually said and
they're gonna be like you're a bigot
yeah it's like okay Netflix net worth is
280 billion whoa really as of October 14
yeah wow whoa look how that is shot up
in the last year hmm yeah because people
gotta watch something
I guess here's the question you know uh
do you think that we're going to see
more companies try and embrace anti-woke
stuff because look at what Bill Maher
said Bill Maher said for the first time
he's playing to a mixed audience he said
people are hungry for critiques of the
woke left
it's like right to the party bill but I
get it uh yeah he's way late to that
party people are starving for stuff like
that but I don't think they're going to
go to broadcast entertainment for it I
think they're finding it right here and
right on YouTube with other people and I
think they are way late I would like to
see The Establishment uh turn it around
I just have very little faith they need
a lot of they need a lot of failures
uh which they haven't had they've been
able to either hide them or you know who
knows what's true anymore like they're
starting to hide uh TV failures now
they're starting you know they're
they're not giving away they don't have
to give out numbers for streaming
services you know you know what I don't
believe
I don't believe anyone liked Kimmy
Schmidt I don't either I do do you watch
it I watched it you liked it I like lies
I'm a I'm a I'm such a big fan of 30
Rock I will tell you why I like Kimmy
Schmidt because she was trapped
underground in a bunker and as someone
who was homeschooled and isolated from
the rest of the world for my entire
upbringing that really resonated with me
so I don't know that one that made the
jokes funny I guess I liked it so this
is cute look I I watch you know I just
binged 30 Rock again because I
periodically watch 30 Rock because it's
amazing and I just laugh non-stop it's
brutally hilarious and then I'm like I I
finished it and I was like okay I'm
gonna watch Kimmy Schmidt I tried to
watch it before I got to watch it
because it's the it's it's it's Tina Fey
it's a very similar style of humor and
then I'm two episodes in with my eyes
just like half closed like not a single
laugh maybe a chuckle like
and then I was like how I look at the I
look at the ratings on Rotten Tomatoes
and it's like award-winning number one
and I'm like dude
I understand how the media lies because
I pay attention to politics I'm looking
at these shows and I'm like I really
don't believe people are are that into
this show and it only got I think Four
Seasons which says to me it was doing
bad people didn't like it the media lies
try and make money and then ultimately
they cancel it because people weren't
watching that's my opinion I Don't Know
Jack Murphy said he liked it
maybe that's just me then I don't think
you're ever gonna get truly anti-woke
sustainable anti-woke or or like edgy
stuff out of corporate media ever I mean
you already have broadcast things you
can't say the f word you can't talk
about this I can't joke about this on
this show so it's really not anti it's
not like a comedy show where I can be
free there's there's always corporations
can be sold to some idiot so you need a
decentralized way for for the comedy to
thrive I think there there are always
limits right people need to understand
this too this is what gets lost in the
Free Speech debate you can't go on
Tucker Carlson's show and say a lot of
things they'd ban you I think Jessie
Kelly was he the one who got well it's
not Tucker it's it's Fox yeah if you go
on Tucker's show with him with that owns
the network and has like owns the ISP he
could let you do whatever you want but
it's it's about
um look the reason we don't swear on
this show is not because YouTube's gonna
ban us for doing it tons of people swear
it's because we've gotten emails from
people being like hey my kids are with
me when the show's on you know would you
guys mind giving the swears down and I'm
like we don't lose anything by not
swearing and there are kids who are
watching and we really want younger
people to like hear the message and be
with their parents I'm like that makes
sense to me so we ask people like you
know don't swear but if you do We're Not
Gonna cry yeah so like the same thing is
true for a lot of shows that will be
like hey you know we have our limits on
what we're willing but like in 2008 you
could swear and it was almost like the
kids loved it and that was when Larry
and Sergey owned the company and then
they sold it I'm not talking about
YouTube I'm talking about uh we got we
got an email we get emails periodically
um from back when we used to swear a lot
more and they'd be like hey man big fans
of the show I was watching last night
with my you know husband and my kids but
I'm a purity and and they were like I
just you know when you guys start
swearing a lot we like don't want our
kids to to hear that kind of language
and then we're like all right I
understand we we want to we want to give
proper values and manners to children
and we can do this show and we can be
something like that that people can
listen to sometimes because we do get
spicy stories when their kids are run I
respect that I do and so we're like
trying not to swear if you swear it
happens you know we're not gonna cry
about it I had a couple of those emails
too I remember calling Bill Gates uh a
special name I can't name here and then
I get an email saying that uh one of uh
the viewers toddlers was just repeating
it running around saying
they're like thanks uh here's my
favorite he's like I'm not gonna and
then people are like I'm not just gonna
watch your show I can't watch your show
because of this so I understand that
that's why family friendly show on my
show as well yeah as long as we're
getting the ideas across and we're able
to talk about important subjects I got
no problem with me okay we won't swear
my favorite was when we were talking
about a group of people that are all in
a big circle together yes and they're
all patting each other on the back oh
yeah I'm complimenting each other for
being jerks and it was a circle of jerks
yes of course and we call it something
else uh more adult and then I got a
couple emails and they were one of them
was like Hey man big fan uh I just had
to spend you know the past 15 minutes
after your show explaining to my kid
what that meant and uh just want to let
you know that like when we're in the car
and I'm taking my kids somewhere and we
put the show on and I'm like we'll say a
circle of jerks all patting each other
on the back instead of you know the
other way yeah yes when it comes to
Comedy though you can't let your
audience decide how you run your show so
this isn't a comedy show if it was
you know take the sensors off and that I
agree with too like when it comes to
Comedy someone could be like hey man you
can't say that around me because I got
kids like it's a comedy show you
shouldn't bring your kids yeah this is
where we get like unless you're doing
children's comedy like why did why did
the chicken cross the road
funny joke that sure was I wouldn't
watch that on YouTube anyway it'd be
creepy probably against you know
whatever that new law is that Copa
whatever the heck it was oh yeah yeah
the anti-kids thing yeah that everybody
freaked out about I want to talk about I
want to talk about squid game yeah we
should talk about squid game yeah what
about it so I think squid game is I I
don't think it's overtly political
apparently you know you were telling me
uh Gary that it was like there's like a
political message in Squid yeah the
writer at least that's what he said my
takeaway from it was communism bad
that was my takeaway from it
okay so now I'm going to say this for
those that are listening spoiler alert
if you haven't finished quid game it's
an awesome show yeah I prefer watching
it in a the original Korean with with
subtitles I think it's fantastic with
the dub you lose a lot of that like
Reverb and like natural sound it's kind
of weird
uh so spoiler alert I'm gonna say it
again we are going to spoil this show to
uh the the
kingdom come there we go spoiler alert
uh so what what was it about you
mentioned that the Creator had said
something and it was like the Creator
called it a fable for uh modern day
capitalism uh but also for life and the
competitiveness of Life uh and that
message I it's it's not subtle at the
end uh which I won't ruin for anybody
but it's not subtle at the end and that
messaging was there and you know some
people can't get past it and I
understand that but I thought it was a
damn good so what what was the messaging
like what do you think the message
conveyed well it's that it's a it
basically it's a cold and cruel system
they're in that Fable you know there is
no resolution except for at the end they
create their own enemy quote unquote but
um that's what I got out of it all right
all right uh just for context okay
because those of you that are sticking
around even though we told you spoilers
are here I'm gonna give you the quick
quick breakdown of the show it's a bunch
of desperate people in debt and then all
of a sudden they get an opportunity to
play in a game but the game is brutal
and you die in it but if you don't you
win I think I think it's like equivalent
of U.S like 35 to 40 million dollars is
the is a translation so it's like 45
billion Korean Won or something now
we're gonna get into uh again I warned
you spoilers I think the whole thing is
the perfect example of somebody who
thinks they're opposing capitalism but
just makes communism and weakness look
really really dumb and the show ends up
being in my opinion more anti-communist
than anything so one of the big themes
in the show is that everyone is equal
they're they all enter the game as
equals and they're allowed to play as
equals and there's an arc in the show
where it's like somebody violates the
equality and so they kill him and
they're like that's the worst thing you
could have done is is strip the equality
but now
here's how the show ends you've been
warned
in this equal system everyone dies but
one person who gets all of the money huh
okay so that doesn't sound to me like
capitalism in capitalism we recognize
not everybody is equal not everybody
does have an equal chance we do want
equal opportunity but some people are
porn some people are rich in this system
everyone is wearing the same clothes in
the same room being brutalized by by the
powers that ultimately result in one
person having all the wealth and
everyone dying that is not capitalism in
capitalism there's too much food people
are morbidly obese and they're they're
homeless people who are fat in communism
everybody wears the same clothes they
have limited access to anything they get
garbage food every day they're like okay
the game's over here's the food you get
and they get trash and they're fighting
each other because they're starving that
to me is an indictment of Communism and
if this guy who made the show is
actually like it's it's actually
capitalism that's bad I'm like it just
goes to show this is a person who made a
great show but was really dumb and
didn't understand they were actually
critiquing yeah it's like they took him
out of a capitalist system where they're
doing pretty bad to a communistic system
where they were doing really really bad
and were executed by the state which
usually happens under communism uh I
mean for like childish swims exactly and
and that's literally what happens under
communism uh look up uh you know what
happened in China what happened in
Russia what happened in uh you know in
Europe as well so there's a long history
there's a long context to you know
people just being purged taken away
another very interesting aspect of that
story is the masks that the very rich
people were wearing were kind of similar
to the same masks that the Rothschilds
were pictured wearing at some of their
private parties in gals a couple decades
ago so I I saw that right away I was
like wait wait that's that's the lead to
doing this and uh you know I I thought I
thought of the movie more of a critique
about the the ruling Elites uh because
it's it's essentially again spoiler
alert rich people coming together to
watch the average poor people struggling
people kill each other over money
um and and you know there's some
important kind of parallels there the
movie I'm sorry the series is kind of
gory so if you're sensitive to that
stuff I wouldn't I wouldn't watch it I
watched I was like Tim you gotta watch
it you're like but but it you watched it
and it is very thought-provoking it is
very emotional
um and it definitely pulls at the
heartstrings in many different ways I
look this
uh there's a bunch of photos from this
Rothschild party where they're all
wearing these masks that are similar to
this the squid game thing but that's
probably what he was doing the Creator
yeah it was a guy right who created it
I'm saying well this story I'm hearing a
lot of different I'm hearing a lot of
different reports about this guy saying
that he lost a bunch of teeth because of
the stress during the production of this
movie I heard that he tried to get this
movie done for years and it kept getting
denied so yeah yeah yeah the the series
uh but but yeah I remember seeing those
masks automatically thinking wait wait I
know I saw these masks before they're at
the private Gallows and private meetings
of the super rich that already do take
place when you do look at the very
powerful people in our world that
manipulate the system put it this way
capitalism isn't the problem communism
doesn't exist it's just this idealized
system we might as well call it
unicornism the real problem is
corruption and corporatism and the left
says capitalism when they mean
corporatism I think that's exactly the
problem I think that's what he's doing
with the masks he thinks that the
Rothschild embody capitalism they do not
no they embody elitism they're the
biggest promoters and pushers of
Communism and this destroyers of actual
real uh you know free markets another
interesting aspect was the fat guy I
mean he looked almost exactly like Newt
Gingrich I talked to Newt Gingrich a
couple times I went up to him asked him
straight up to his face hey what did you
do at the Bohemian Grove when you
shipped in specifically male prostitutes
uh and he was sweating up the storm I
did this like five times to him he
really doesn't like being asked those
questions but we got to understand here
there is some level of of reality when
it comes to super rich people coming
together in the middle of the Woods
doing very weird things that does happen
it's called The Bohemian Grove there's
also other kind of speaker societies and
offshoots to these secret societies
remember when Bilderberg was a
conspiracy theory yeah they said it
didn't exist they said it didn't exist a
few a few years ago and I was there at
the meetings be like it's here it's
happening they're like no he's crazy
remember when they sent that dude from
the guardian down and it was really
Charlie Skelton he came there to make
fun he's now my friend Charlie Skelton
is set down there by the guardian to
make fun of the people outside they sent
him down there there he's like there's a
bunch of loonies there's a bunch of
crazies he literally got followed
everywhere assaulted by police officers
they raided his hotel room they raided
my hotel room the police officers acted
like the Gestapo against any journalist
trying to do any real reporting against
the Bilderberg Group and he came out of
it shook saying hey I thought these guys
were crazy I came here to make fun of
them these guys are honest I'm being
followed by police everywhere I go and
they're literally trying to arrest me
for just trying to take a photo of of
David Rockefeller and Henry Kissinger
walking down the street together I got
arrested at Bilderberg way too many
times too uh they said it wasn't real
they said it was a yes it doesn't exist
and it's like you could literally just
stand there be like here it is yeah and
they'd be like sorry sir it's a private
events the Bilderberg you know group
meeting and and then you look in the
newspaper and it's like nope not a real
thing yeah it doesn't exist crazy yeah I
remember there being like this is
absolutely absurd but but when really
rich people do come together they do
really weird stuff and there's a lot of
weird stuff that I I I even experienced
that Bilderberg there's even weirdest
stuff happening at the Bohemian Grove
and this is some of the stuff we know
about what about the stuff we don't know
about so I thought I thought this this
was a perfect time to talk about the
bigger elements of these Elites who do
very Sinister things so that's that was
me the the larger conversation of squid
games but that's always the criticism is
always the corrupt Elites I don't you
know when they talk about like oh
communism oh come they never actually
implement it because it's not possible
it's impossible to do and then when they
criticize when when the left criticizes
capitalism they're really just angry
there are they're elites with
centralized power able to do really
messed up things and get away with it
because of how much power they've
accumulated that's not what capitalism
is supposed to represent either and the
problem is communism doesn't exist right
they say that like they every time they
try it they get some weird form of you
know genocidal authoritarianism
capitalism at its root is just people
with capital from their work can
reinvest that into making more projects
however in our current system which
mixes it we end up with a lot of
corruption and then you get a left
saying aha this proves capitalism
doesn't work and it's like no actually
the problem is is the corruption I don't
care who's who's doing it or why the
corruption bad when you use the power of
government to destroy your competitors
in the quote free market that's not a
free market that's that's communism
that's government direct intervention
into the free market that's preventing
the market from being able to express
itself from being able to speak for
itself because usually in the free
market if someone does something good
they get promoted they get business they
get Commerce they get people going to
them because they know that their
reputation is good when you have
multinational billionaire Elites play
playing by a different set of rules not
paying taxes getting subsidies literally
getting taxpayer-funded money getting
bailouts and restrictions and rules that
punish their competitors and only help
them that is not a free market we don't
have that we have multinational
corporations globalists some people call
them that are literally the ones calling
the shots creating policies that screw
you over while they get whatever they
want for the grabbing I got it I got I
gotta bring it up again for the 800th
time my friends you've seen it in almost
every segment I've done over the past
few months Democrats in the Civics poll
believe the economy is good Republicans
and independents think the economy is
bad 70 percent of independent voters
believe the economy is to some degree
bad either fairly or extremely 88 of
Republicans say either fairly bad or
very bad 54 of Democrats say the economy
is very good we got the story from
Breitbart consumer sentiment crashes as
confidence in Biden Economic Policy I'm
sorry collapses Breitbart says the
University of Michigan's preliminary
October rate of consumer sentiment fell
to 71.4 from 72.8 in September Richard
Curtin the survey's chief Economist
explained the downturn consumer
sentiment has remained for the past
three months at the Lowe's first
recorded response to the shutdown of the
economy the Delta variant supply
shortages reduce labor force
participation rates will continue to dim
the pace of consumer spending into 2022.
there's another less tangible factor
that has contributed to the slump in
optimism confidence in government
economic policies has significantly
declined during the past six months so
there you go my friends there are people
who are living in a cult
they believe for some reason I just I
literally don't understand how they how
they think that things are are going
well
we are being told by Jen sackey that oh
it's good that prices are going up
because it means that things are being
sold we saw that article that was like
inflation is actually a good thing it
means you'll make more money no no no no
it means you can't buy stuff it means
you're saving his savings are being
gutted this reminds me of Bernie saying
that bread lines are a good thing that
means there's a bunch of bread like no
you're wrong you're wrong about that are
waiting in line to eat it's a good thing
yeah yeah uh I I we're in this weird
limbo right now where everything is
we're still getting out of uh you know
the covid economy uh I I'm selling a
house right now and the market is still
good but that I mean you can see can I
buy it yeah
it's in California yeah yeah but you can
keep that sorry well here's a question
though is is uh is so right now in rural
areas rural property is absolutely
Bonkers yeah like property that used to
be a couple hundred grand is now going
for like triple but what about in San
Francisco is it going down it hasn't
going down yet it hasn't skyrocketed up
uh San Francisco is it's not the best
test because they don't have a lot of uh
inventory so when a house goes on it's
usually gone and it's bought up by a
company usually who in their right mind
would move to San Francisco right now
don't know I don't know we just had a
poll come out recently saying half the
people half of the residents want to
leave you guys have poop all over your
streets and that's what's the deal
that's not even an over-exaggeration it
started drifting out into the outer
streets it used to be just in the
tenderloin or on Sixth it's like rolling
down the street it's rolling down
California Street going down 101 which
they just blocked off because you can't
drive on 101 anymore you can just ride a
bike on it or poop you can poop on it
too if you like nice uh yeah it's
terrible it's terrible I've seen things
in California I never thought I'd see
yeah I was in LA and I'm I was going to
a shopping center and then right in the
middle of the street this large homeless
woman just walked right in spread our
legs and squatted and just went to town
oh and I was like
what is happening right now this is
crazy welcome to the city I remember
doing a walk and talk that was unedited
and I was just walking down San
Francisco down where I think City Hall
is at it or the state capitol city hall
City where City Hall it looks like a
steak and I saw a lot of people taking
the vaccine uh on the streets
and I saw a lot of uh different stuff
but as I was filming as I was walking
there was a lady screaming on the top of
her lungs and I see police officers hear
that and literally run the other way and
I'm like this is what's happening one of
America's biggest city with some of the
highest rents how in the world do you
live there not for long I'm leaving I'm
getting the hell out I was it was enough
are you are you able to tell us what
options you're looking at
um Texas uh any place in the country
away from a city yeah I don't want to
live in a city at all anymore uh my
house got you know I grew up in San
Diego like never had my car broken into
lived in San Francisco for 18 years had
my car broken into twice a year wow
twice a year and my wife had hers broken
into it's all the time there's always uh
have you considered Chicago
no uh surprisingly enough no nice City
New York City is also very Charming with
uh you know a lot of people trying to uh
stab you big rats big huge rats that
would they didn't they didn't oversell
that one I couldn't believe it when I
saw that but no no cities I'm done with
cities sorry go ahead no no I I just the
the crime I don't know how they cut they
can say the economy is good when we have
uh how many we have there's a help
wanted sign in California every
everywhere I go every shopping center
has at least five or if it's not empty
it's a cult yeah if it's not an empty
building it's a help wanted sign yeah
you go to the supermarket out here and
there's there's a sticker every on like
every other uh like refrigerator door
and on every aisle multiple times saying
500 sign on bonus and these people are
just like I think the economy is good
yeah I try to go to a restaurant earlier
today today the first two all closed
when it said it was open your Waffle
House is closed that yeah
I've seen a lot of things
will die before my eyes but when I saw
Waffle House closed my heart felt like
it was being just strained and I was
like it's real it's happening at the end
of the world true story uh there is a
Starbucks near my house that ran out of
coffee because the supply line chain wow
ran out of coffee had to close yeah oh
my gosh I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I
wanna use a gloat when I was saying like
hey you should get emergency food a year
ago because you never know like
sometimes it rains there could be a
flood the road might get closed and you
gotta you could have some food and water
in the closet you can pop up when you
need it and all these lefties were like
oh Tim's so dumb he's telling people to
buy emergency food and now we're going
on like year two of supply chain
collapse yeah yep well you know go to
your store there's food I'm not saying
people are starving right now but I'll
tell you this the prices for emergency
food has like doubled or tripled some
shops don't sell them anymore so if you
got it you're good if you don't yeah and
Bitcoins through the roof uh what's it
called I already made a list here
Bitcoins up stocks bonds copper all up
confidence crashes near decades low as
the Washington Post is is literally
writing articles that are entitled
America needs higher longer lasting
inflation I mean how more criminal could
you get when you look at inflation it
predominantly makes people poor already
the cost of living astronomically High
the cost of food higher than it ever has
been for the average American in
everything for the basic cost of living
is going up wages staying the same what
did they call it was it Reuters who
called it a great reboot yeah a great
yeah a great reboot yeah no really I
think Reuters did right yeah I think so
the reboot it's like guys we know what
the great reset is we know the word yo
man Bitcoin is what like 62k
yeah imagine how many how many people I
remember uh because we talked about it
I'll I'll just say this right right away
like why Bitcoin works it's
decentralized it is better than all the
other cryptos in my opinion and when
you've got a failing US economy and
failing U.S policy Bitcoin is global and
decentralized so it's much much more
difficult to actually manipulate now a
lot of people say oh but Elon Musk
tweets and he manipulates it nah you
know you don't get it we know what the
real value of that coin is and basically
right now that means you're buying at a
discount but I remember when it hit 60.
but a bunch of people were like
oh you know it's a bubble and then it
fell down to 30 and they started saying
like see that proves it and I'm sitting
back like okay sell your Bitcoin then
and they did and poor people were
selling now it's back up over 60. it's
his highest point isn't it
um I don't I don't know exactly I have
to double check that to make sure I'm
accurate
61
351 dollars per coin not quite the
highest it looks like it was uh close 63
or something
still I mean April of 20. yeah 63 and
April 15th
essentially it's it's where it was it's
at about its highest point again people
need to understand this is a sign not of
this is not good news okay if you are if
you're a cryptocurrency holder what this
really means is your dollars are
becoming worthless yeah so when we when
we're in uh back in November when we
were talking we had bill ottman on the
show and he was like yo by ethereum and
I was like okay and so I bought some
more Bitcoin in ethereum and then within
a few months it was at 30k and I was
like whoa Lumber went up at the like
basically the same rate so I think it's
actually happening is when Bitcoin
skyrockets like this what it really
means is not that it's getting more
valuable the dollar is getting less
value yeah now they're saying I saw one
report the dollar will lose half its
value in the next like decade or so next
13 years
it has to I mean how much did they print
over the last two years like Six
Trillion I think yeah I mean like four
to six trillion even though arguably
it's still BS uh the Dollar's not based
on anything and it's just a big joke at
this point but when you print that much
over the last year it has to fall and
and they've been kicking the can down
the road for I mean longer than I've
ever seen in my lifetime I've seen it
economies come and go nothing's been
like this uh but yeah anytime he's like
even before the internet anytime you
start seeing some old guy trying to sell
you gold you know the well we're about
to go into a recession uh and like the
same thing is happening here except the
new gold is Bitcoin and it might be a I
would recommend it uh or or financial
advice no Financial advice I don't know
anything I used to own a comic store but
I keep a lot of cash in my safe
um that's where that's what I do because
yeah I'm not really sure I mean I I
don't know how bad it's gonna to get
it's this is the worst I've ever seen it
and with the since the shoe hasn't
dropped yet uh and it's gonna be it's
only a matter of time really uh I don't
know I think it's going to get worse
when people realize demand is about to
spike for Thanksgiving and Christmas oh
yeah and with already constr like
constrained supply lines that could snap
it yeah totally travel already super
expensive and you know we talk about how
the vax mandates are are really bad but
a lot of people aren't talking about how
the Biden Administration literally wants
to pass a 3.5 trillion dollar bill which
one of the provisions is a surveillance
Bill where the Biden Administration will
be literally looking at everyone's bank
account to make sure that everyone's
paying the IRS if they have over 600 in
their bank accounts I mean this is a
massive surveillance bill this is a
massive incrosion into people's personal
Liberties people's personal freedoms and
they're going to be paying for this bill
by taxing everyone over 600 when they
print the money out of thin air attacks
the poor it's insane it just seems cruel
it's more cruel than logical in my
opinion I completely agree and nobody's
talking about it like nobody's upset
about it you should be very very upset
about this this is something the the
Democrats in their bill and their
spending Bill want access to the income
and outgoing money from your bank
account if you have at least 600 bucks
yeah and Nancy Pelosi and Janet Yellen
are literally arguing saying this is
going to get the billionaires guys this
is going to go after the billionaires
because billionaires have accounts with
600 bucks yeah yeah this is going to go
after what they've been after the whole
time the middle class they've always
been after the middle class when you're
attacked the richest tax the middle
class you can tax all the rich people
you want well it's not going to make a
difference a lot of the multi uh you
know billionaire corporations a lot of
these super wealthy people call for more
taxes call for more regulations because
it will destroy their competitors as of
course they save their money in a lot of
different safe havens so they're fine
literally paying every single dime every
single penny which the IRS knows exactly
how much you owe you make a mistake
they'll send you a bill right away
saying no no no no no we know exactly
exactly how much you owe you you unders
understated your taxes you know why not
just tell people if you're going to be
doing that anyway but but you're gonna
have to pay every little last cent of
this to go into a hole that literally is
going into nowhere meanwhile the
multinational corporations get to do
whatever they want play by a different
set of rules as you're getting screwed
every single day and your dollar that
you worked hard for is being devalued
right in front of your eyes inflation is
a tax on your savings and holy cow are
they taxing the crap out of you but
Bitcoin is a hedge against that
I'm not giving anybody advice but I'll
tell you this I'm particularly happy
with my purchase of Bitcoin over the
past several years I I remember when it
was at uh like 1300 or whatever several
years ago and I was thinking to myself
like
like dude I just wish I would have
bought when it was a couple hundred
bucks and then I I was like I'll just
buy some now I'll just put some of my
savings into it and boy was that a good
idea
anyway Luke and I were talking about the
other day when you know I was like
bitcoin's gonna hit a million bucks and
then Luke was like and then we're gonna
be thinking back to when it was at 60
and being like why didn't we buy when it
was at 60. and that was a joke I made
like it if you look at the trends some
people are projecting 200k in the next
month or two yep I think so I do I do I
don't know but if you look at the trends
similar Trends happening it should Spike
and Max Kaiser also called it and he's
been he's been within margin of like his
predictions quite a bit I'll just put it
this way man I don't advise anybody
other than the US dollar is becoming
worthless uh yeah you're twenty dollars
if they raise the minimum wage to like
20 an hour it'll be worth ten so yeah
yeah that's just what you said that the
dollar is worthless you know the Big Mac
index I think they call it you ever hear
that yes they they gauge the strength of
economy by the by a working-class
person's ability to buy a Big Mac
something like that and so it's like how
many hours do you have to work to
purchase a Big Mac
and so they'll look at a bunch of
countries and a lot for a lot of
countries like you got to work four or
five hours to get one big mac that's a
bad economy in the United States it's
like you can work for one hour and
actually get two Big Mac yeah so it's a
good economy right now
if a Big Mac costs five bucks and you're
getting 10 bucks an hour you're getting
two Big Macs an hour
but if they increase the minimum wage
what's really going to happen is that
Big Mac's going to go up in cost and
you're still going to be getting two Big
Macs per hour the amount of money you
make is not relevant to the cost of the
materials and the labor to produce the
product the left doesn't get it there is
one benefit though when it comes to
Imports because raising the wages in the
United States won't change imported
goods from other countries which maybe
they're trying to do hoping that okay
the economy is collapsing but what if
like your computer was cheaper because
everyone or not cheaper but you're
making more money now you can afford to
get it the computers are still going to
get expensive but they're hoping they
can like outpace the the important goods
as they Outsource more and more of our
manufacturing and products overseas so
this just sounds to me like we're giving
more of our power to countries overseas
so that's not good first of all second
of all I'm very glad that you guys as
Bitcoin investment are going up but at
the same time that terrifies me because
it lets me know that everything that I'm
earning and everything I'm doing trying
to pay off my own debts it's for nothing
the value of my dollar is falling no
that's good your debt's becoming
worthless too yeah that's great so it's
like I was sandwiching so this is what
the US does though the U.S purposefully
inflates so that the debt they owe is
worth less so if 20 bucks can buy you
two cheeseburgers
and you let's say let's say I borrow 20
bucks from you to buy two cheeseburgers
I owe you the equivalent of two meals I
wait until inflation hits and the 20
bucks can only buy one cheeseburger and
then I'm gonna pay you back one when you
gave me two you see how that works
that's the trick China is also
implementing a very similar policy
they've been acting like they have blank
checkbooks and they've been writing
checks all over Africa all over Latin
America and buying a lot of influence
buying a lot of resources buying a lot
of manufacturing buying a lot of
relationships that slowly and surely are
overtaking the United States and their
sphere of influence in those particular
regions so it's very interesting to see
China implement the same role but
instead of just giving it to
multinational corporations they're using
it to build their country to make sure
that they have enough natural resources
for their people as they're of course
more of a nationalistic government
meanwhile our government to keep selling
us out every single day yep and it gets
rooted on uh by more than half the
country every day and that's the thing
we have to fight is that influence and
that that apathy or or either rooting
for one team or that apathy uh and we
see it it's all throughout our culture
uh and yeah I worry about the future uh
I've got kids
uh I'm gonna buy a you know buying a
house soon I don't like I have no idea
what we're getting into that's why I
just I think it's a good time to not
give up but like uh fortify your future
fortify your future but if you can uh by
getting out of a city but not everybody
can uh and the the one thing I learned
through through covid was I I never paid
attention to like local elections San
Francisco's a waste of time but
um that's something I'm going to pay
attention to every day now every time
everywhere I move I'm gonna know who the
dog catcher is I'm gonna know who uh
everybody who Lords over me is I want to
know everything about them uh and that's
on that's where I can make the change
that's I I don't know if it's gonna work
but uh I I want to know I gotta show you
guys what I think is one of the funniest
stories I've seen in the economic
collapse this is from the Salt Lake
Tribune shipping container Apartments
opening delayed by global shortages
developer says
okay okay this is this is hilarious the
cost of a shipping container is
skyrocketing the cost of transporting is
going way up
they tried to make low-income housing
out of shipping containers and now they
can't open it like this is like a fire
truck on fire isn't it it's like the
perfect definition of irony I know we'll
use shipping containers to create large
cheap you know low income housing and
now that shipping containers are spiking
so they can't even do that no this is
the perfect economic collapse store I
saw this I couldn't I just wow I've been
doing some research on them they're
expensive to transport which is why
they're having why they're not the best
thing to do and they're also you don't
know if they're going to be dirty or
that they ship to toxic uh chemicals
there's no insulation once you insulate
them in the inside they become much
smaller they're only like eight and a
half to nine and a half feet high anyway
six feet that was in Salt Lake City
where it gets pretty cold look at this
this is crazy imagine living in that
have you guys have you guys seen Ready
Player One the Pod yes no it's how they
live in the stacks yep that's what it is
that's exactly what it is and the Pod
and yeah they have yeah these are up in
San Francisco they have them
um look look I love the idea of getting
a shipping container for yourself and
like burying it and having a little
clubhouse or something bunker or doing a
tiny house but this is the stacks this
is what we've been like
this is 1984 when the guy lives in that
crappy little cute concrete cubicle
welcome to your dystopian nightmare
California you will own nothing and you
will be happy in California you can only
get single-use containers uh like one
shipment version containers but
everywhere else apparently you can have
like they can transport transport
transport animal blood you know
phosphorus you don't know what's going
to be in it we're going to be breathing
in so I would at this point recommend do
not at least go look into it but it
seems a lot worse than I thought it was
I was just watching Ready Player one the
other day and then when I saw this I was
like oh man so like all the mobile homes
are like stacked you know and people
live in these really awful conditions
well this is what you're going to get I
gotta be honest the these shipping
containers are probably better living
than New York bachelor apartments huh
have you seen how bad New York is uh
I've been there once and it was uh well
recently they've got apartments that are
like it's a closet yeah and there's like
there's no bathroom here it's the same
as San Francisco then so for a studio in
San Francisco was 3 500 bucks a month to
4 000 a month to rent why that is a good
question especially after you know
before how does someone afford to live
there uh they they go broke they eat a
lot of freaking cup of soup making a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
pooping in the street I have no idea
well they make a lot there's a lot of
money floating around that town there
was in 2019 best economy I've ever seen
wow uh the Trump economy uh in my
lifetime I am the amount of money that
was going through Calif San Francisco in
particular with the big Tech they're all
centered their patreons there uh
Twitter's there downtown yeah and uh
they and you know houses are expensive
there's always been money rolling
through there and there's always a
million people this is before prior to
covid but there was a million people a
day that would just travel into San
Francisco so the population doubled on
every business business day and I I've
never been able to explain it like a
normal house I don't know how a a
gardener lives in San Francisco and he
must have bought his house 30 years ago
maybe it's like 10 gardeners all sharing
one Studio maybe and they all just like
sleep in bunk beds it's like good
amenities
um nice weather you probably know better
than I do and then you got the mountains
to the north uh in the East you have
like what's the city you have a salsa or
sausalito's up North but like then you
got like kind of suburbian beautiful
Farmland to the east you know you got
the 101 the PCH
so it's it's it's located a nice spot
and the temperature is incredible if
you're down low in the Hills it's cooler
and then you go up and it gets really
warm like up above when the sun's
hitting you yeah I I've never loved City
living so I've never really gotten my
head right why people would want to be
that close to people and I lived there
for 18 years
uh and I you know I I know you've lived
in cities before I don't know what
attracted people to it originally it's
just it sounds like the worst thing in
the world and I always think San
Francisco too there is that for if
you're in your 20s and 30s I get it uh
as as a family guy I don't uh you you're
not taking your kids to the tenderloin
yeah in San Francisco I moved there in
2016 for a year paid three thousand
dollars a month for a one bedroom and uh
they were trying to sell me mushrooms on
the street when I would walk around that
was something interesting
um but other than that I never left the
house my car got broken into the day I
went down there to look for apartments I
had my backpack in my back seat came out
and the window was shattered it was gone
that was rough strong start it's it was
terrible I think it's an illusion I
think a lot of people I mean like
there's parts of it that were beautiful
there was parts of it that were nice and
there were parts of it that were fun but
I think a lot of it is an illusion
people build this up New York is this
fabulous City San Francisco New York
smells like sour milk pre-interest yeah
it does it's all based on pre-internet
living before the before you could get
everything shipped to you it will you
you could only find like cool jewelry in
the in the jewelry district in Manhattan
now you just order it online they make
it and send it to you from Japan or
wherever Malaysia China China
everybody had to say it yep uh I I think
well and then the mom and pop capitalism
which I love is dead yeah Soldier uh so
you had a comic shop in San Francisco
yep what was the whole process of
starting it and then selling it oh it
was God it was great this was uh back in
2003 when I bought it it was was uh Hey
I want I want to buy your comic store
and the guy said yeah and we signed one
piece of paper
uh and that was it and you can't do that
now
um and the landlord was cool I I got
lucky he was an old guy he liked me and
he gave me he said a thousand bucks a
month and he only raised it 25 bucks in
10 years wow and he felt bad when he did
it you can't do that now once the errors
take over uh as time went on the city
got more intrusive to the point where uh
they did a point of sale Purchase Tax
through the Food and Health I don't even
know how they wanted to get into my
taxes then that they wanted to so I just
got rid of the point and sale purchase
I'm like I don't have it anymore so you
can't tax me and you know because I was
having to submit it and it was a way for
them to look at and that's their way to
sneaking in and looking at your taxes
the city so they started doing more and
more intrusive stuff like that no more
parking bikes everywhere you can't you
can't drive anywhere uh public
transportation got more uh more
expensive crime went up uh my place got
broken into a couple of times they
couldn't get in but it got broken into
it was like regular yeah when the front
Windows broken front door is broken and
it just got worse and worse and worse
over time so it did start out nice so
but you you no longer have this comic
shop no I sold it I sold it uh back in
2013 I'm happy I did my wife owned a
business in San Francisco for a two-bit
well she had two salons and it went to
one for 15 years and she did great she
did fine but she had the deal later on
it was there's a homeless guy sleeping
in the in the front door every day
uh and and that you can't just scoop
them up and get rid of them you can't
call the cops they won't come and get
them anymore San Francisco if it's uh
this was before the they changed the 900
you can go and steal 900 with the stuff
and they won't prosecute you they will
not prosecute you
um 20 years before that if they broke
into your car they did something that
was even short of being violent you just
went online and you filled out a form
and they might come my friend Kelly
Cutler was working with the homeless up
there and said that every morning at 4am
they'll bring like a fire truck or some
something down the street and just fire
hose the homeless people and make it so
that they get off the street what are
you serious no I know I mean I've been
here in the water cannons before at
protests that's pretty severe I doubt I
I don't know I I let's let's look at the
resources to that in San Francisco you
said I haven't seen that I mean you've
never seen that no I've never seen him
leave a street uh it would have to be
like Obama coming through or something
like that that was back in the day but
they they are a constant force all the
time especially down on 6 in the
tenderloin which I brought up but it's
spread out because they gave him cash
for the longest time that San Francisco
gave him cash that's how they that's how
they're fighting uh drugs they give them
clean needles and uh cash money once a
month yeah I'm gonna get in touch with
Kelly and see if I can get her evidence
on this because that's where I heard all
about this from and then I'll bring it
on the show maybe talk about it next
week it was when I heard that that they
would be hosing the homeless because
they couldn't get them to move otherwise
without getting violent I forgot what
they uh what they did when this was a
long time ago but when uh Obama would go
there quite often for a fundraiser and
every time he came in they just bought
him bus tickets
huh wow say that South Park episode you
ever see it where all the homeless
people come to South Park so then they
get them yes yep yep and they get
everybody all the homeless people to go
to to Venice
that's what they do didn't didn't know
that concert or something no no on South
Park they'd sing the song they're like
in the city city of Venice right next to
Matt's house that was a funny line I
love that one because Matt Stone yep
uh they've been doing that for a long
time giving them bus tickets together
they stopped doing it in California
because they're like it's great it's
great here we get cash we get needles
why would we want to leave uh ever yeah
I I I worked um I worked for a homeless
shelter in California and
people don't understand what causes it
they just don't get it and it's and it's
it's really really frustrating when you
have these bleeding heart types who are
just like why can't we just take like a
house and then put the homeless in it
and they do this thing where you'll see
like high level Progressive like famous
progressives be like there are more
empty homes in America than homeless
people and I'm like okay and those are
that's a non-sequitur the reason the
homeless people are homeless has nothing
to do with an empty house it has
everything to do with their with with
many of these individuals choosing to be
homeless a lot of I hear a lot they're
like mental illnesses the cause of of
homelessness it is it is a cause but my
experience the biggest cause that I
experienced was people saying I want to
be homeless they they enjoy living
outside they don't have to worry about
much people are giving them food and
money fresh air but it's it's not even
that it's like they don't care they're
under a bridge they don't care you will
not be you can't you go to them and say
look there are a lot of homeless people
who are definitely in in hard times who
want to get out of that right who want
to find a place to live but my
experience most of them were just like
I don't mind sleeping under a bridge why
should I get a job people give me free
food all the time so I go to sleep wake
up walk around get free food go back to
my bridge and go to sleep
how you solve for that I honestly don't
know unless you can't right you can't
there's there's uh there's I mean you've
seen it but there's three types of
homeless people there is the one who
wants to be homeless there is the
mentally ill and then there's drugs uh
drugs is the vast majority and ever
since uh the opioid crisis it's double
triple quadrupled uh the amount of
deaths in San Francisco uh eclipsed the
amount of uh they're they're I would say
this there are the legitimate Trope of
homelessness that the left thinks
someone down on their luck Hard Times
loses their home that exists definitely
and there's a lot a lot of people like
that have met many people like that but
it was not the majority it was like one
in ten yeah if if and that may be
generous one in ten most people that we
encountered would say something like get
away from me I'm not going anywhere near
your stupid shelter I want to be
homeless
yeah they wouldn't say it's specifically
like I want to be homeless they would be
like I don't want to have anything to do
with your garbage and if they ever did
come in they'd come in for like clean
clothes a shower and then leave right
away
yeah they uh I I don't know the exact
story on this but they during when
everything was locked down they gave uh
they let homeless people in to a hotel
or a couple hotels in San Francisco
there was a death in two weeks there was
fires inside they were caught dealing
drugs within a week it was just a
complete s show uh and uh they had to
continue it because they they couldn't
like how bad would that look if they
stopped it but they were there was cops
there all the time and the hotels like
uh wishing they hadn't had done it but I
I I would love to find a solution to
homelessness but that means
arresting homeless people that in in
Northern California they announced that
they would in turn homeless people if
they were deemed not mentally fit yeah
they would take their their paychecks or
any money they had coming in and seize
it and then lock them up
that's the only like that's the simple
solution because I tell you this when
you go up to homeless people and say
Here's a house and they go no what do
you do are you gonna drag them into the
house and lock them in because that's
that you're gonna have to these people
don't understand these leftists are
naive they think everyone assumes the
world they think everyone thinks the way
they do they don't realize that people
believe different things they think
every conservative is a grifter because
how could you possibly believe that say
Jesus is the son of God or something
like that I I don't believe it therefore
they don't either and they're lying or
they're crazy it's like yo you are not
the Arbiter of Truth and morality you
don't know what you're talking about
this is what makes it so hard to
actually solve these problems the the
arrogant
exactly and and judging the World by
their own standards all the time uh
you're not going to save everybody I
mean you know what what's that saying
that the left sees the world for what
they want to see out of the world and
the right sees it for what it is I don't
know if it's a correct thing I don't
even know if I said that right but well
you made it up if you did yeah there you
go I mean there's the the you're not
going to save everybody we need it
doesn't mean you don't try but uh as far
as the homeless problem is because it's
not something you can throw money at
it's like the drug war that was
ridiculous it's the same thing uh you're
gonna have to fight the problem at home
and you're not gonna there's there's
hobos there's there's a whole culture of
do you know do you know what hobo means
hobo vagrant bum Vagabond all different
things vagabond's the obvious one that's
like a wander a Wanderer a traveler but
I learned this hobo
is a person who is looking for odd jobs
and is just passing through it means
Homeward Bound
I don't know interesting so I hope I
know that when you'd see the cartoon of
the guy with the stick with the thing in
it it's because he's going back I guess
the idea was people would go out looking
for work and then when they failed they
would start heading back taking odd jobs
along the way so they didn't have any
place to live they didn't have a job but
they were looking for some work hobo and
then bums I think were people who are
like around the town not working
vagrants were usually like unable or
unwilling to like it was like typically
a negative like layabout and then
Vagabond was just somebody without any
direction there's traveling around doing
whatever interesting huh yeah I've been
called that a couple times
yeah that one's not really derogatory
that one's just like you're a Wanderer
and again you can only get hurt if you
give power to words I'm seeing another
story on Twitter I don't know if we're
ready for a transition but I'm seeing a
pretty wild story that I definitely want
to talk about but we can still continue
on this subject if you want well you
want to give your final thoughts on the
homelessness thing you really chime in
but then we'll I'll pull up whatever A
lot of people are like let Gary speak so
I'm trying to try to you know give as
much yeah I know what are you doing I
can't help myself sometimes okay
uh but but you know it's such a
difficult problem the government in my
opinion is exacerbating it it's making
it that much worse
pretty much yeah
I like that word I like home free free
sounds a lot better as I'm establishing
my uh you know relations with homesteads
all across the United States I'm getting
a lot of emails people being like yo we
have a freedom of stand here in South
Carolina North Carolina Georgia Florida
so so thank you for your emails I I love
being a vagabond I love staying in
parking lots uh but that's a whole other
story in my trailer and my RV I like to
act like a diva when I smash through the
door be like I just got out of my
trailer but in reality uh it's my travel
trailer that I live in but that doesn't
matter but um again the government is
exacerbating this problem I think a lot
of it is lack of Economic Opportunity I
think a lot of it is mental illness I
think there's also a lot of other
elements that we can't even quantify in
words but when you look at mental
illness when you look at lack of
Economic Opportunity that's everything
that the government has been literally
pushing for and creating along with big
Tech social media so that problem is
going to be exacerbated it's only going
to get that much worse people are poorer
people are unhealthier people are in the
worst mental Decline and and that is
only getting more exacerbated the more
government gets involved so so Luke you
mentioned that there was a big story on
Twitter I can't help but notice the
number one trend is uh WWE Smackdown no
I saw I saw Epstein trending to a couple
hours ago that's because Bill Clinton
was uh in the hospital and then Bill
Gates what's the story uh but this is
something that kind of hits close to
home with me because I'm seeing the
front line coveted 19 Critical Care
Organization the flccc just tweet out
that their PayPal was suddenly shut down
along with Facebook uh restricting their
account and their group of medical
professionals and doctors that are
literally putting out Protocols of
medicines of supplements of of medical
studies that have helped a tremendous
amount they're very Pro mask uh yeah
their front line covid-19 critical care
workers there there are a lot of the
doctors and they just got attacked by
multiple uh social media platforms and I
know a lot of people people that they've
personally helped so so to see this kind
of attack on medical professionals on
doctors on people who are quoting the
data the science and actually going
after the studies to me is a very big
deal another and another grave
escalation in the censorship Ryan long
has that sketch we've talked about where
I don't know you've seen Ryan long right
here yep he has that saskatchew where
he's like all the experts agree and then
Danny walks in he's like I read the data
and I came to a slightly different
conclusion and then he just punches them
yeah and he's like no all the experts
agree again and that's that that's how
it's been for a long time I mean there
have been a bunch of studies
uh I won't get in the details of some of
the studies let's just keep it vague
that have been pulled down scientific
reports on uh on certain cultural issues
that get deleted because they're
offensive you'll end up with in this
instance I think the CNN story is a
really really good example Sanjay Gupta
sitting down with Joe Rogan finally
being forced to admit joburgan was right
a doctor prescribed his medication and
then what happens CNN doubles down on
the LIE to see big Tech going after you
know doctors
look man
I don't know what to say well we've
already said 50 billion times and it
just keeps happening
I'm not completely pessimistic because
there's been like you know just because
something bad is happening that doesn't
mean the world's going to end doesn't
mean that it's it's completely over
there have been some games like we're
talking about Dave Chappelle getting
defended by Netflix it's a good thing
Netflix still kind of sucks but I just
don't know man you know
uh Bill Maher you know came out he said
he's not getting the booster
right you've got Kyrie Irving coming out
saying it's his body his choice he's got
One Life to Live and one body to have
you've got Joe Rogan in his fight with
with with uh Sanjay Gupta and you have
massive amounts of protests all over the
world
developing right now in Italy will it be
fair from cnn.com thousands protest as
Italy's covet pass becomes mandatory for
workers
they say
anyone who is on a payroll in the public
or private sector must have a green pass
with a QR code as proof of either full
vaccination recent recovery from
infection or a negative test within the
previous 48 Hours employees who go to
work without the past risk a fine of up
to 1500 Euros 1730 and suspension
without pay employers could also face
fines if they allow staff to work
without it wow yeah that's uh it's
substantially worse than here in the US
exactly and the way that they
implemented this was really Sinister
because in Italy talk of like the covid
you know vaccine passport it was first
deemed a conspiracy theory it's crazy
it's not gonna happen here and then they
started to implement it with restaurants
and indoor dining then they started to
implement it with travel trains buses
planes can't get on any of those if you
don't have the green pass and now their
latest rule here this I don't I I don't
even want to say rule their latest
decree here by the Italian government is
that you can't work in there in the
public sector or private sector if you
don't have a green pass if you don't
have a QR code that says the government
allows you to work and if you do work
you get a fine of a thousand five
hundred euros
um and you need a vaccine to be
compliant every six months with this
quote green pass or a test every 48
hours which is unfeasible so what's the
I I a question so what's the option if
you say no to all this uh you're going
to jail you're getting fined until the I
mean 1 500 euro five fine for going to
work and not having a green here's
here's the best part in the United
States
if you are fired because you didn't get
vaccinated there was a mandate it's
considered a voluntary resignation wow
and in many states like New York you
lose unemployment benefits so nurses
that get kicked to the curb literally
have to find another job right away to
make sure that they could even pay the
bills so we're in phase two Italy went
through phase three and four we're
seeing a lot of countries implement the
same policies only on different
timelines but they're doing the same
thing it's common it's again it's
already here Los Angeles has some of the
most strictest uh covid-19 vaccine
passports that they're going to be
implementing CNN has been cheerleading
it's saying it's awesome it's great you
know getting permission slips from the
government for every basic activity is
so awesome you know the same government
that runs the DMV yeah I definitely
trust those people to have a domestic
permission slip passport system I mean
it's just ridiculous it's it's insane
and and people are standing up to this
people are protesting in Mass I've been
tweeting out photos that show huge
amount of people there's also some fake
photos there's some disinformation going
around but I'm trying to confirm a lot
of this I have some people in Italy that
I'm talking to but now unions doc
workers are coming together and they're
doing a quote indefinite blockade of the
ports in Italy with them saying we're
going to block this until you get rid of
this domestic passport permission slip
system so it's going to be a very
interesting showdown in Clash that we're
going to see unfold in Italy in just a
few moments from now it needs to happen
soon because as you guys know that once
they implement this stuff it doesn't get
unimplemented it's done it's expanded
there's no deadline there's no deadline
they're not going to say hey if everyone
is free of covid we're going to get rid
of this or if 90 or 80 they usually do
this you can't tell someone to sacrifice
for something that has no end to it this
is why we're setting up free namasteam
uh there needs to be a free dhamma stand
in every state uh and you're setting
this up uh West Virginia yeah oh that's
brilliant is there it's not like it's
going to be an actual big city or
anything but we're gonna have a lot of
space so there's going to be a lot of
big communal aspects to it where people
can come and you know we're we're we're
sorting it out we're gonna be growing
our own food we're going to be doing a
lot of sustainable living stuff Ian's
going to build his free Dome geodesic
dome we're gonna we're gonna try and do
things in the most uh environmentally
friendly and economically friendly way
to be like self-sufficient because
look man Nick it's the great reset it's
coming right they want you to own
nothing and be happy well as long as you
have some land and the ability to
produce some of your own stuff then
you'll at least own some stuff and if
the supply chains are breaking down what
I'm really interested in is you know
what can we make in Freedom stand what
can we what can we get out of the ground
what can we build ourselves Luke's
talking about trade routes and stuff can
we get medals and things like that and
then start doing construction or even
like sourcing raw materials things like
that Ian's talking about pulling carbon
from the air to make graphene maybe this
Sparks the graphene Revolution because
we can't get iron anymore right you can
pull the carbon dioxide out of the air
then deposit it onto like a copper
Palladium Alloy at like a thousand
degrees centigrade and it'll deposit
graphene oxide
um that's one way to do it there's other
methods too you can take rubber trash
and then hit it called flash graphene
where you hit it with pulse it with
lasers and then turn it into a fine
layer of graphene that requires a lot of
electricity and lasers we need to figure
out how to generate a lot of electricity
yeah
yeah uh it sounds much better in the
Chad for sure it does it's Solutions not
if we just stare at the problem like
this all day every day we're all going
to go insane and then it's going to end
so we have to fix it yeah it's funny
they set up the autonomous Zone in these
cities just by trying to steal land or
whatever they're colonizing yeah what do
we do we we rightfully negotiate a
treaty for you know settlement on this
here land and then set up our autonomous
Zone it's not an autonomous Zone you
know we're just like a normal place with
like business no it's it sounds like
it's weird we were talking earlier about
things flipping we we're seeing people
on the right I don't know I wanted to
say too conservative like thinking about
communes and going on their own which is
it's good you know there's always been
the Preppers as well uh to be fair and I
you know we have to do this soon we have
to think about these things soon so one
thing when I talk about it on my channel
I've been talking about it for a long
time is you know nobody's going to come
and save us like nobody's coming at
Trump ain't going to sweep in and fix
everything even if he wins in two years
the midterm elections might be a slap on
the wrist but you know right now they're
all in on this most of the government is
in on this they're just playing their
stupid game and they're resetting on us
and there's like there's stuff I'd love
to say but I I didn't want to say it you
know on your channel you know when we
were talking about earlier and I won't
say it here but uh you know until we
decide we are going to end this those
rules like I said are implemented
they're implemented they're not going
away ever and now this word mandate is
just part of our language now and we're
completely cool with it so we went from
our emergency emergency Provisions
mandating that people stay at home for a
couple of weeks to Gavin Newsom
mandating what a business can sell on a
you know a toy aisle you know and that's
why we chose West Virginia you know you
could choose New Hampshire Florida Texas
I think Texas is too dense and that
means it's susceptible to you know
leftist manipulations and things like
that for a variety of reasons what
happens we see this in West Virginia
where there will be like a gun range a
shooting range and it's noisy uh there
actually is one up you know not too far
from here it's a public land where
people go shooting you're not supposed
to do it use it as a range apparently
but people do hunting training or
something all the neighbors can hear the
gunshots all day every day and they're
fine with it but Liberals are starting
to move in from DC because they want to
get away from The Nightmare they created
and go to West Virginia where it's
conservative when they move in they're
told when you buy this property you sign
this disclosure acknowledging there's a
shooting range you know on the other
side of the street which presents some
dangerous risks and a noise issue but
you accept these things when you move in
and they say yeah no problem
then they tell their friends to move in
and say once we get enough people we can
vote to shut down their range huh and
that's what's been happening things like
that there was like a farm that had like
a dairy farm and it was stinky and so
people moved in and they were like you
acknowledge as a farm here the smell is
you know something that people are
concerned about they said no problem
once they sold all the land around it
the people voted and said shut the farm
down and then all of a sudden you own
this land and they're like sorry the
cops come in and say the people have
spoken and then you can't run your
business anymore that's what you got to
watch out for that's why I'm worried
about you know Texas because it's
happening in West Virginia too now
that's because West Virginia people
don't know this is about an hour from DC
it's not that far away from DC so New
Hampshire might be a good idea but then
New Hampshire is uh I think New
Hampshire what has going forward as a
free state project which is protecting
it and expanding the freedom West
Virginia has the inverse problem they
have a lot of people trying to come into
the eastern part that being said though
West Virginia has lost a ton of liberals
from the other more urban cities so I
think West Virginia is a good bet New
Hampshire is probably I think in the
long term we're actually looking at uh
setting up shop in some capacity in New
Hampshire so maybe buying a small piece
of land that way we have a place to be
in New Hampshire in the event the free
state project becomes very prominent
because as long as I've been taught
telling Luke non-stop like New Hampshire
I've been screaming about New Hampshire
I've been sending you property there a
few weeks ago Luke sends me solo posts
I'm like dude this is good right here
because there's already a freedom stand
there there's a great guy called Jay
noon he could fix and build everything
he's been teaching me pretty much doing
man camp which he does and he helps
people figure out how to get out of the
cities and learn to actually be
self-reliant he's a great guy Jay noon
if you ever heard of him great awesome
part of the free state project but here
he has his own freedom freedom estan
um in New Hampshire I want to build the
forge yeah and uh you know there's a lot
of freedom in New Hampshire
um and a lot of opportunity so I love it
there I go there for the Summers Florida
for the cold cold Winters and of course
I hear what you guys uh for the
foreseeable future
all right yeah yeah really dense though
and you got that border problem right
these people flooding into the border is
a big risk to Texas in terms of
maintaining you know their
sovereignty yeah no it's it's California
was fine 20 years ago California was
fine like when I was growing up thinking
about like San Diego was a right-wing
military town
and Los Angeles was pretty Centrist San
Francisco was always weird but it never
ran the state now it runs the state and
now we've seen what happened like Las
Vegas you know they they had these like
crazy mask mandates and I was just like
God you know gangsters used to run this
town I was just there I'm like it's oh
it's it's so conforming and it was kind
of a turn off and then Arizona's the
same way so I yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if uh if Texas flips if
Florida flips it just depends on what
county you're in at this point so Texas
and Florida are like teetering between
left and right now there's been some big
changes like on the border it went
Republican Miami went Republican West
Virginia is the second most Trump
supporting state in the country and so
I'm like I like it you know New
Hampshire is good but I think in order
to get a good space you got to be like
you got to be kind of far away from the
urban center whereas here
we get West Virginia we're in the
tri-state area but we we we're setting
up for example in West Virginia and it's
like an hour and a half to the airport
so you still get a big urban center
airport not too far away but not too
close we we wait a lot of options I mean
I was looking at northern Maine I was
like I'll take what I can get but
satellite internet it's not going to cut
it and bringing people out to the middle
of nowhere is too difficult we looked at
rural Pennsylvania that would have been
awesome I really wanted to like find
like a dying town and bring industry
back and just like get more jobs and
stuff but uh maybe maybe we'll do that
with the ferdamastan area and more
people will find jobs and more industry
will grow and we'll we'll be investing
continually in the space to build stuff
and set up a business you know Luke
wants to get have his own gun shop so
that would be fun and and a training
facility and yeah you know growing your
own food yeah yeah owning a shop was
brilliant it was the most Freedom I've
ever had or except you know working for
on a YouTube channel it's great being
your own boss is ABS it's that's the
American dream you know and you don't
need to be rich I never made a ton of
money at the comic store I was so
freaking happy for most of it uh and I
I'm I'm happy now except for the world
falling apart around us uh I'm happy
it's it's hard to work out in my head
sometimes but yeah I guess the only
problem I had about moving out of
California was Finding internet I mean
that that's that was you know like you
said satellite internet's not going to
cut it so I'm gonna have to have it put
in myself
especially yeah like you have you know
if you go too far out there's no way
you're gonna get it uh that's the only
problem because I would love to be out
in the middle of nowhere nowhere near a
city with not even within 100 miles yep
but that's not enough option right now
there's still a ton of country I mean
Texas is cheap that's even now like
compared to compared to California
everything's cheap so yeah uh Crazy
Prices man but how about we do this
super chats if you haven't already smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become members at timcast.com to help
support our work and we are having an
event coming up October 23rd to get sold
out basically instantly however
for we so the initial plan was we were
going to give a day's advance notice to
members who gave 25 or more we're
keeping it locked at that level because
25 members are still struggling to get
access because of like the high demand
but some people are canceling
periodically and tickets are opening up
so the best I can say is I apologize for
the kind of Catholic nature of this we
are going to be opening up an auction
two members so that we'll have five
auction slots where you can you know
choose how much you want to pay and then
this is our compromise like we can have
people who don't have time to like try
and be there clicking the button every
every few minutes but we could also you
know some the people who have time to
dedicate can get the ticket for free
other people can just support us by
doing the auction system and then we'll
get people to come and help support the
event and everything like that but
people are canceling sometimes and I did
see a super chat from one person said
they needed to take it for their
girlfriend she was able to get one so
I'm glad to hear it and if you send in
emails we will respond we um we might be
able to accommodate some people who got
you know the short end of the stick due
to how the system was operating so we're
gonna try and make sure we can do the to
the best of our abilities helping people
out I gave out some tickets to my
audiences literally minutes gone I was
like what this is crazy so uh yeah
people want to come hang out we got to
expand this grow this build this oh man
you know I we could do a stadium like a
like a stadium but like a big Auditorium
but then it's just more like a it's not
the same thing you know yeah what we're
planning on doing is it's not it's not a
bar it's it's open to all ages I think
you have to be 18. I don't know but uh
so it's not all ages but it's like 18
and over and uh we're gonna have a stage
and there's gonna be some comedy from
Ryan long so it'll be fun all right
let's let's read some of these super
chats smash that like button if you
haven't already Joshua hickey says
anyone else see Peter Thiel donating to
people running against the likes of Liz
Cheney and other swamp creatures said he
wants Trump ASM to continue for
Generations in the same ilk of DeSantis
interesting hmm
all right
Chef as does it Tim Poole and nerd
Roddick the ultimate team up there you
go nice
Dan vask says George what's that about
uh that is an inside joke for myself too
long sorry uh
but Dan vask is Great Dan vasque uh you
might you guys might have seen him he uh
he does cover songs and he's saying uh
toss corny or Witcher got a couple
million views yeah he's got some he did
the theme song for our show but yeah the
George thing uh George is out there
he'll know very cool right now inside
joke
all right Captain says Tim you were
right about the ports the trucker
problem isn't truckers it's trucks CA
carb emission law doesn't allow any
semi-truck over three years old to
operate at the ports look up opening the
Port of Los Angeles 24 7 isn't the game
changer biting claims interesting
punk rock fox says Tim we did it
yesterday I was upset because I could
not get my girlfriend a ticket guess
what we got today see you in West
Virginia I'll have my Mohawk up for you
buddy let's go Brandon also I am we're
all going to be there yep I'll look for
Mohawk let's go Brandon and I'm really
excited to see uh Ryan Long play uh
perform we haven't really like worked on
any schedule for playing music but I
think Ian's gonna be playing right sure
Ian's gonna play play a set and rock out
and everyone's gonna be super stoked
yeah we got to do a couple songs
together
I've got two that I've been working on
I'm practicing them I wonder if I can do
like one or two songs so I'm like this
is gonna be this is gonna be a lot of
work events like this people need to
understand it's tough you know
oh yeah I just I just did like a tiny
event it was very very tiny compared to
this and it was a ton of work but it was
fun uh meeting everybody it makes it
more real Let's do an acoustic thing
yeah I'm thinking just acoustic but Ryan
long's a good drummer yeah
interesting we can bring the digital kit
yeah Nathan O'Connell says the last time
Netflix tried the woke stuff with cuties
they lost seven billion dollars in value
because everyone canceled their
subscription they aren't siding with the
woke anymore and they're not losing
value over Chappelle I don't think their
stocks that go down over that they're
going to be like people like it you know
Chappelle's insanely popular I didn't
know he had it special until the drama
they're terrible at promoting their
specials but I mean they don't need to
was Chappelle get around and within two
weeks everybody had seen it and it's if
it wasn't for squid game people would uh
it would be the most watched thing on
there and blazing 64 says Gary and Tim
need uh need you to discuss Falcon and
the Winter Soldier series haha we did we
were talking about that before the show
before the show but not on the show
sorry my general assessment was that it
was not overly woke it tried to be
political but kind of just didn't really
get a strong message but I liked how U.S
agent was the media claimed that he was
the embodiment of white supremacy and
white male rage but it turns out to be a
Redemption Arc hero that is like made to
look good so take that media I I totally
the writing was all over the place uh
and U.S agent uh cap was much better
than uh he was the best character in I
thought he had the best character Arc uh
but I thought it was uh filled with uh I
I get into the Weeds on this stuff but
intersectional feminism I call it the
MCU
and uh yeah they it's a long story but
it goes back to Captain Marvel and you
know at the end yeah a terrible movie
terrible movie but at the end they had
falcon Falcon didn't even fight his own
bad guy oh I call her Freckle Jesus but
she came up and uh she got killed uh she
got killed by by Carter by Sharon Carter
so why are you not even fighting your
own bad guy at the end and people say oh
you're just nitpicking and stuff but no
if you watch the entire story Falcon
does he deifies his villain who is
basically the head of antifa she's like
a you know and he's like chewing out
doing this uh you know he's projecting
right in front of three uh three
politicians that just happened to be
standing there that survived a plane
crash and his big suggestion or
helicopter crashes do better at the end
that's what it is you know why I didn't
like uh Captain Marvel
and I thought a lot about this I watched
a video comparing Captain America to the
film to the Captain Marvel film and
they're like in Captain America you have
Steve Rogers he's weak he has no
strength but he has he has good moral
character he's willing to stand up for
those and stand up for himself even
though he knows he'll lose here's a
scene where he throws himself on top of
a grenade proving that even though he
isn't you know a strong physically that
he's a good person who's willing to do
what he has to do
he's then granted power and be and and
then his his he has the strength to back
up his ideals Captain Marvel was always
strong and her powers were locked away
by a man
so in the Captain Marvel story she's
mean she's nasty and in the end she
doesn't have a Redemption Arc she has a
self-realization I actually found her to
be the villain I found her to be very
villainous not that the militaristic you
know uh group that she was working with
was good guys no one has to be the good
guy but her whole Arc is basically she's
a bad person she's a bad person she's a
bad person now she's strong and a bad
person and arrogant and I was like and
then in endgame
when I was in the theater and she
punched Thanos the whole audience the
whole theater groaned no no joke so
there's that theme it's like there's
that scene where Thanos has The Infinity
Gauntlet he has everything and then or
yeah he has almost everything no no he
doesn't have them all right he has
almost everything and if she comes down
yeah and then and then he's like pushing
against her and then she she's holding
his like he had butts her and she
doesn't Flinch and then everyone groaned
oh yeah and then she grabs the or no he
grabs the stone and punches her people
were like
I was I was laughing when I cheered when
that happened in my theaters they
cheered when she did it they did when
she got punched by that they were like
yes I was in rural Maryland when I saw
in the game and so it must have been
this a conservative area because it was
like I was in a particular conservative
area Western Maryland very everyone
ground I was laughing when I heard it
was like and then when all the women
came down and that scene the audience
groaned again and I was laughing yeah I
was like I knew it yeah I'll point out
again Disney annihilated that series The
Infinity Gauntlet they should have made
The Infinity Gauntlet and made it like
they wrote it because it's amazing and
people die and it's horrible to see your
your favorite hero get ripped apart by
the infinity gems it's just that's what
they needed more of not these Invincible
trash characters I liked uh did you
watch what if uh yes I did I thought it
was kind of dejected like it's clear
people recorded their lines in passing
yeah it's like as part of your contract
you're gonna do this movie and then just
read this line real quick into this
microphone okay thank you during a lunch
hour right exactly but I really did like
this the finale I I liked like you know
the Watcher breaking his up spoilers
sorry but I liked it I didn't think it
was that great but I I was entertained
by it I watched it my favorite
um I'll tell you this the doctor strange
one
was wrong and I fixed it did you hear my
rant on the doctor no I did what
happened so you've seen it right yeah
spoiler alert everybody should have seen
it by now so Doctor Strange in this
universe is he's bringing um what's
Janine that's her name right no what's
uh what's the woman's name I'm blanking
I went oh my God this is bad for me too
I'm not a nerd
what's the name of the doctor
Palmer Dr Palmer what's her first name
it's Rachel McAdams I know the actress's
name
Christine Christine why did I think
Janine weird anyway okay so anyway in
his uh in this universe well I'm gonna
start over in the original movie he's an
arrogant prick he invites her out she
says I'm not going to something like
that he's trying to pass somebody in a
storm crashes his hands get crushed he
can no longer be a doctor so he starts
losing his mind because he's like his
whole life is destroyed eventually he
finds the Mystic Arts and becomes a
sorcerer Supreme and that loss drove him
to becoming the hero of the topping save
the planet in the what if series they're
like in this version of reality he
brings Christine with him she dies and
in trying to figure like learn about
life and loss finds domestic Arts
becomes sorcerer supreme but eventually
decides to use the time Stone to go back
in time to save Christine but he can't
because it's a fixed point in time that
created him if she doesn't die he never
becomes sorcerer Supreme you know what I
thought was going to happen
what I thought was going to happen was
that when he's like you know desperately
trying to like bring her back to life
and the Watcher talks to him and says
you can't change a fixed point in time
it is the loss of Christine that drives
you to become the sorcerer Supreme I
thought he was going to go back in time
and Destroy his own hands on purpose
creating the timeline where he destroyed
where his life was destroyed and then
what that does is it kind of sets in
motion this Loop into the original movie
where you realize he didn't have to be
crippled that in the original timeline
he just lost Christine but even though
they didn't stay together he was willing
to sacrifice everything that made him
who he was in order to allow her to live
and they didn't do it no and it was kind
of like whatever and then there's like a
weird thing where the source where the
ancient one like turns him into two
stevens or whatever and I was like yeah
man and then it ends the same way anyway
my way was better yeah I think so I I
mean I think they just wanted it to be a
sad ending I think that's pretty much it
and plus they stole something from
Doctor Who having the fixed point in
time that's straight up a doctor who I
just I gotta stress like how amazing it
would have been if he's like to see the
scene where he's like trying to save
Christine and the universe is collapsing
and the Watcher's like it can't be done
because the loss drives you to become
the sorcerer Supreme then he's like what
if I gave up something else
and then it was like it would have to be
something of tremendous value it's like
what if it was everything that made me
who I am his hands and then he creates
their own timeline so he basically
punishes himself how awesome would that
have been that'd be cool yeah anyway I'm
totally lost yeah yeah it's okay
yeah go ahead all right Cole uh
stiverson says Tim please talk about the
globalists there you go that's what Luke
is here for yes that's right
all right Dennis s says Dems have media
media runs on trades trades have mostly
conservative Republicans Etc love you
guys listen every day let's go Brandon
let's go Brandon indeed absolutely
all right
JH schwalbach says with all the money I
give in super chats to Gary and Tim my
wife is sure I'm buying porn keeps
married spicy hail Friday night is it
Friday night tights right yep AZ x-ray
girl Geeks and Gamers RK Outpost and all
thanks uh to Tim for having nerd Roddick
moist oh no problem we're more than
happy to have you on thank you and and
it's porn in a way intellectual porn
maybe yeah I hope all right toxic man
flu says Gary has an awesome story of
Hope and success I never would have made
it through the last two years without
Gary comics division culture casino and
many others in the fellowship thank you
all right on I like how they're using
the word Fellowship I tell people to
stop using the word community
language yeah yeah The Fellowship of the
Ring yes we got so many super chats this
is from Sarah statharos she says George
Exclamation point Exclamation point I'm
not gonna read all of them so many
that's George George
is gonna love that that is brilliant yes
I mean there's a bunch of super chats
saying the same thing yes George uh is a
supporter of my channel has been for a
long time and uh every time he would
give a big super chat we just yell his
name and it became a thing afterwards
yeah Samuel bonan says vax mandate
taking my job soon but fear not although
most of my time is taken up by OT I've
accumulated over 20 projects books and
games that I can start building culture
with wish me luck or hire me oh um you
can always send an email to Pitchers at
timcast.com but I do have to be to admit
we are just like dramatically swamped we
get a lot yeah
all right let's see
Furious Phil says JC Tim you have nerd
Roddick AKA Gary start asking him
questions let's go unicorns do not crap
ice cream and fart rainbows they don't
Oh I thought they did yeah
all right yeah
Vex [ __ ] killrog says hail Gary hope
you're enjoying Babylon 5 before the CW
reboot come for it too is that true yes
and they're oh spruzzinski's riding it
too so it's they got the original
Creator and uh it's still probably going
to be
oh I know a lot of people have hope but
now you can't you can't go back home
again and even if the original Creator
comes back they're going to capitulate
to especially it's on the CW did you
like Picard no I hate it really because
I hated it with a passion I couldn't
stand it really why uh it was the
Federation apology tour and they uh
emasculated Picard throughout the entire
series it became about the girl who's
the key to everything uh plus uh Patrick
Stewart just looked tired yeah he was
like joking like this how old is he is
80 or what you know he's pushing 80. I
think he's gonna be 79 and they shot two
series back to back and they have them
like running upstairs and freaking sword
fighting and it's just ridiculous it was
absurd it was a d it was just another
deconstruction of a of a traditional
character which they have been doing
over and over again I liked it
um I I it wasn't the Next Generation it
was just kind of like uh you know going
to a reunion of friends and seeing Riker
and and Diana and Picard and I was like
you know oh look there they are again I
would love to see a continuation after
Deep Space Nine and they haven't given
us anything meaningful it's just been
reboot and prequel and I'm just like so
what happens you know well they'll
probably eventually get around to it
they've got like four other shows or
three other shows coming out supposedly
I guess I was the one reason I like
Picard is finally I'm like they're
showing us something after Deep Space
Nine because that really bummed me out
that we get the Dominion war and it's
like let's go back in time and talk
about stuff as a no no no what happened
this was big the cardassians come on
there are four lights ah come on but
then they come back and we don't see
anybody we really recognize until later
in the show that was an afterthought by
the way they didn't originally want to
do that really like have have like a um
like Riker and everything yeah that was
an afterthought they actually shot a
different ending and they CG at the very
end I won't ruin the end well it's
terrible it's a couple years freaking
terrible and I still I still owe people
a review on it uh I I think it's the
last Jedi of Star Trek I think wow
I reviewed every episode I was like I
felt like I was having an aneurysm by
the end of each episode The Last Jedi
was is the worst piece of media but you
have you heard my theory on this no Ryan
Johnson sabotaged Star Wars on purpose
because our culture is stagnant have you
seen Knives Out yes I've seen Knives Out
no I hate it really yeah I liked it I
liked it a lot I thought it was great
people love it though I didn't think it
was a little preachy but I thought he
did politics well because he has that
scene where the liberal the leftist
woman is arguing with the Maga uncle and
I think it was decently an accurate
portrayal of of common opinions the guy
wasn't a racist Nazi the woman was like
your typical liberal and they had like
made real statements about it which was
funny and then you had the the the young
liberal daughter who turns out to be a
Cut Throat who's gonna sell out the girl
whatever I thought it was good when I
saw that Looper was good but weird and
the story kind of didn't make sense but
I was like it's fun and then when I saw
the Last Jedi I was like there's no way
this was this was an accident he even
says kylo Ren says let the past die kill
it if you have to and I was like he did
it on purpose
because he was probably like yo all we
do is reboot remake same thing over and
over again and he sabotaged that's my
opinion that's my bet
uh you would have to sabotage to be that
bad you would have to try to suck that
much and I would say like when when the
plasma our plasma is arcing in outer
space I'm like dude he was sitting there
thinking like what can I do to make this
as offensive and awful as possible I
want it I want Die Hard fans to reject
it so when you see them firing the
plasma it's arcing in space I'm like he
did that to piss off the Die Hard people
are gonna be like what
how how or using hyperspace as a weapon
I mean like they never did did that
before which changes the entire lore
which people care about like that's the
thing is people actually right I call
them rhianne Johnson Rianne Johnson
doesn't care about Star Wars and he made
that pretty clear he was happy with how
you know he's an already he's an artsy
filmmaker he likes to piss off half of
his audience because he's cool this is
Star Wars just make people happy but yes
they did go in there and deliberately
deconstruct Luke uh the symbolism of him
drinking uh you know the blue milk out
of a giant puppet throwing the
lightsaber away puppet boob throwing the
lightsaber away you know looking like
The Big Lebowski uh you know like
complaining all the time getting his
butt kicked by Rey for no reason
whatsoever not really training him and
then you know he ODS on the force that's
just like I hate Star Wars and I'm gonna
do a movie now it's ridiculous yeah dude
Star Wars is done yeah it's it's done
um
some of the games I guess what's what's
the game they just did recently people
liked
but I don't know Knights of the Old
Republic no no that the OG Knights of
the Republic was yeah and they have a
writer coming in to screw that do you
need that I mean you just said it's
amazing and I'm not the biggest gamer in
the world but you said it's amazing to
be changed it was such it was one of the
best games I've ever played in my life I
was addicted it was so good so good they
brought in a writer who uh who one of
the writers who likes to drink fake geek
tears one of those type of people type
of people who just hate the fandom uh
that's part of the thing I I kind of put
I kind of I defend the fandom once in a
while they they get picked on a lot by
creatives and stuff always have
you know but it's always been behind the
scenes but now since uh social media is
around they love saying things like
toxic fandom or in cells and all that or
you live in your mom's basement it's
like I thought you were supposed to be
for the Nerds how about the Nerds I'll
just put it this way uh you know I think
we we share a lot of opinions a lot of
people who are upset about the
destruction of this content and uh the
rumor in is anything but a mom's
basement we are
um well well mannered and developed
adult individuals who enjoy
entertainment of the sci-fi and fantasy
nature and it's being ruined by people
who don't care about it who have been
handed the Reigns by big corporations
and I think that their goal is they take
a look at their market share and they're
like we got too many dudes how can we
get more women involved and they're like
what women like and then they just make
some mash up garbage it doesn't work
well they bought I mean they bought Star
Wars to bring more boys to Disney that
was the whole point of doing it and then
they nuked it yeah the sequels were just
the worst garbage I've ever seen in my
life first of all the force awakens is a
shot for shot remake of A New Hope yes
and then you get the Last Jedi which is
the worst film I've ever seen in my life
at least the room is funny and how bad
it was it became a cult classic and then
I just love oh uh the emperor is not
dead actually and The Last Jedi didn't
matter and he's here and my favorite
part about it is he like he wants to be
Rey like the emperor is like I'm going
to be a young woman and then he's like
strike me down and I will possess your
body and then she goes never ah then she
strikes him down yeah I I like and he
kills himself no no he becomes right
like he said yeah the way the way he's
set up you're right he he should have
won at that point and he didn't or did
he uh who knows based on maybe he was
transitioned he did but that was the
weird thing to me when he was like I
will take over your body I'm like that's
really weird yes the emperor was trans
the whole time and that was the cat that
was a character Arc he wants to be a
young woman and then I guess he wins
though because she she kills him
yep and then kisses kylo Ren
[Laughter]
remember the whole time
yep
and then he could you know Han Solo dies
and then he's like well he still has a
son
do it he looks him in the eyes do it all
right all right uh Falcon race falcon
niser says nerd Roddick Geeks and Gamers
and Tim Cassie to team up to make sci-fi
content we can't depend on the
entertainment industry to entertain us
anymore so we have to make our own
entertainment I'm down
um I've been saying before we want we
want to do like a Comics section kind of
like Shonen Jump where we do like like a
few weekly releases of various series uh
serieses Series so if you know people
who have um good story ideas and they
want to just start cranking out weekly
chapters or something we'd be down I'd
be down for that I don't know if you
guys are there are there are hundreds of
them out there hundreds hundreds
thousands gotta find the good one you
gotta find the good one though so yeah I
mean they send me stuff if I saw
something great I'd send it your way
make sure it's good yeah uh make sure
it's really really good uh I I basically
just I think the comics are all
regurgitated at this point I'm not
entertained by them I used to love the
Justice League so much the stories where
I just big fan and the X-Men when I was
little now I'm all I I started to get
get into Manga and Anime and now I just
think they're doing a better job my hero
Academia Academia email does superheroes
better than Comics today
I mean you got you got that's just it's
kind of amazing that's the case yeah I I
wouldn't Read Manga or watch anime for
the law I mean I like some of the anime
but manga would not read for one it's
reading backwards and I never you know I
was an American comic book snob but they
I people have sent it to me and I
finally I'm into it now yeah death notes
good I like death note a lot I like
Attack on Titan uh I haven't I haven't
watched a whole lot of them somebody
sent me a bunch of uh uh one piece so
I'm getting into that right now I
haven't gotten into that you know the
problem is it's so big I'm kind of like
it's big yeah it's taken me a little
while to even figure out what's going on
and then they finally sent me a Blu-ray
of uh my hero Academia which my kid has
been trying to get me to watch it's
brilliant yeah I'd really like I think
they do superhero so much better than
yeah and it's it's original you know and
to see to see anime doing original uh uh
superhero stuff I'm just like man
where where are you at America they gave
it up they had it they they CR we
created this stuff in the 50s the Golden
Age all this stuff these superheroes and
now it's just trash
one guy yeah Japan is so far behind
because um well I mean there are gay
characters in there but not everybody's
gay so once everybody's gay in uh in
manga then they'll catch up to America
there's a lot of good stuff you know
um but I definitely would like to to
make some Comics
um you know have some of that content
and maybe even make our own shows and
stuff we get to that point there's a
there's a there's a bunch of stuff that
I I haven't been watching a whole lot
recently but um someone mentioned era
fuetta I'm pronouncing it wrong I don't
know it was a show I watched a big chunk
of until I reached the the I watched
every episode until the latest and then
I'm like okay I binged it now I gotta
wait for them to do it more episodes uh
Black Clover a lot of fun I guess people
don't like it I thought it was cool my
Academia I thought was really great the
the uh man I used to read every single
Naruto when it came out every Wednesday
at the scanlation every Wednesday for
years so I'd be totally down to make
some fun new cultural content and do
these uh Comics did you see the uh
Donald Trump in the Death Note One Shot
no they made a legitimate Canon Death
Note chapter with Donald Trump in it no
way yeah so it's basically a kid gets
the death note and decides to sell it to
and Donald Trump is like America will
give you you know 50 trillion or
something like that it's it's good I
thought it was great
all right let's see we got
spider bro says Hey guys huge fan and
you're right me and my cousin tried to
get breakfast at IHOP Denny's and Waffle
House both IHOP and Denny's were closed
and Waffle House was only taking to-go
orders because they only had two
employees wow
this is stuff I have never seen I mean
it's this is uh yeah this is kind of the
the beginning uh the breaking down you
know when you see the the organized
gangs going in and you know shoplifting
out of Walgreens I saw one guy uh oh you
might I won't repeat his name here he
retweeted and saying oh well you know
this is what you get when the chain
markets come in and take over the mom
and pops he's not totally wrong but this
is happening to the Mom and Pops in San
Francisco too they're just not videoing
that that's it's happening to them too
uh that's just that's society breaking
down that's that's the beginning Darth
meerkat says I can't wait I can't wait
to play the division IRL have you played
the division uh-uh it's about a pandemic
that like wipes out a bunch of the
cities and then you're in the in part
one you're in New York and it's pretty
cool to be in Manhattan and it's like an
apocalypse and there's a like Rogue
faction start taking over so
firefighters start like they actually
take flamethrowers and become actual
firemen and they're trying to purge the
disease and they end up going crazy and
just killing anybody they're like it's
too risky they're infected you have
regular gangs you have paramilitary
groups it's a fun it was fun game and
then in uh part two that you're in DC
and it's like you're in the white house
and it's abandoned yeah fun game plus
you get real guns like the guns are all
based off of real guns so it's it's you
know it's fun
all right uh Sarah uh
safatos says George George George George
thank you for the big super chats to say
George
dragon dragon balls deep says Tim given
all the gun stuff y'all do you must get
in contact with Mike Glover of FCS he's
the real deal also I want to see Dave
Smith versus vosh debate love the show
shout out to Ian
uh I'd totally be down to host Dave and
watch that'd be fantastic but I feel
like you know is vosh the only one
willing to actually sit down and express
himself you know his ideas he does a
good job of of giving his ideas a lot of
people think he's he's wrong but I can
respect that if he wants to come and
speak and be wrong as a person be wrong
yeah but I I don't think it's completely
wrong I think we agree with him a lot of
stuff I think there's yeah there's just
like core issues we clearly don't agree
with I think most Americans regardless
of your beliefs agree on like an
overwhelming majority of things
but it'd be nice to get someone else on
the left to actually want to come and
have these conversations the problem is
there's two kinds of people on the left
who want to come on the show outside of
vosh either people who are small and
don't have big channels can't really
articulate the thoughts as well and are
just trying to get some kind of you know
notoriety yeah and people who are
grifters who want to come on and do
stupid things to make a scene and then
get us in trouble and then make viral
content for themselves we should have
Andrew Yangon he sent us a gift he sent
a book to them he did but it came with
like a generic print instead of like a
signature okay like that's you can sign
the books and just go that's cool he
sent us a book we he should probably
come on he's not on the left but he's
kind of like can represent that he quit
the Democratic party that's pretty big
the forward party yeah Ford party oh he
did uh yeah yeah we tried to have him on
a while ago and he said he he would try
to do it but then he got way too big way
too fast because I was a big fan I I
donated the max to Yang in in the early
days I was like this dude has got a huge
list of comprehensive policies and he's
right about a lot of it he was fairly
moderate and he actually looked at he
looked at tons of different areas where
he thought he had ideas
and then he just kind of just started
playing ball with the Democratic party
trying to get support and I was like
yeah I heard he worked for CNN yeah
um I would love to talk to him and I I
have a different point of view than Tim
yeah Scott Anderson says Luke 1 000
yards forever what's the current rate
for 50 BMG got a story for you Tim what
is the best way to get to one of your
reporters
um
I think it's what tips at timcast.com
probably info I have no idea uh you can
email pitches at timcast.com we're
really trying to you know we gotta we
gotta get to that point I try to let you
guys know like
um a lot of the stuff that we're we're
doing outside of the show is like we're
investing in like doing new shows like
it's not easy to just make a show and
then try and make money doing it you
know so we're really hoping that other
shows can become you know new ways to
get new people to be involved and things
like that but uh we're working we're
growing
all right let's read a couple more just
because we did talk quite a bit
Jerry Latt says hey Tim 10 years working
maintenance on metal container closing
machines the information on this process
at times can be esoteric I imagine it
could be useful to your future endeavors
I'm willing to give advice and help you
choose that path to work on metal
container closing machines
maybe for Freedom stand we could do
something like that I do we do have a
nice little Hill and I was like we could
bury like we could get like three
shipping containers and just bury them
and then have three little like little
dorm like hangout places or make them
stores you know they have like the town
I would love to have like a little a
little western town like the sheriff and
like General Store yeah that'd be cool
free Thomas Dan
all right we'll just do a a couple more
here
all right let's see
I don't know what that means so I can't
read it
R Barrett says let's talk about some
Bond rip or how they are systematically
killing strong male characters like
He-Man Bond Indiana Jones Etc
yes that's what I was talking about with
uh Luke Skywalker that was uh the
beginning the beginning it started a
little before the Last Jedi everything
that's going on but it's very deliberate
and it's I guess it's only deliberate to
like hardcore nerds who like not only
just pay attention to Star Wars they pay
attention to the whole realm so uh when
they see something similar happening to
Picard and to James Bond and to Luke
Skywalker and to Captain America and to
Iron Man they tend to start thinking
that there's something nefarious going
on and and there is there is there's a
since the time's up uh me two times up
little moment in Hollywood after Harvey
Weinstein it was a huge power shift and
what they decided to stop doing is uh
they start they started writing
uh basically uh
Marxist Powerpoints and it sounds insane
it does it absolutely does until you see
the paperwork until you see that
um not not even not only just BLM but it
sounds like it's from BLM you have the
rodberry foundation that's owned by uh
you know uh Ron berries kid his Heir and
there's a ton of money in there and it's
supposed to be a workshop for writers uh
Gene rodberry and they made up some
paperwork basically on what you can and
can't write in Hollywood anymore
and you can't write uh I mean some of
the stuff actually sounds like it sure
it makes sense because it's not the 50s
anymore but some of it is nuts they tell
you how you can write uh I handle
capable person and how you can't write
they can no longer be the person who
overcomes their handicap you cannot
write that anymore
they Revel in it I guess yeah yeah it's
supposed to be bad it's a bad stereotype
so anything that perpetuates a
stereotype is gone from Hollywood you
can't show uh a a woman or a man
mentoring a woman in any way shape or
form anymore a woman can mentor a man
but you cannot portray a man mentoring a
woman can we do you have a list of these
rules yeah I can send them to you why
don't we make a short film that violates
every rule brilliant a handicapped man
who really wants to Mentor a woman but
he overcomes his handicap to become the
best Mentor she's ever had yes I would
love that woke everything woke I mean
it's so it's so ripe for being made fun
of yeah it's great I mean Saturday Night
Live rating if they were good and they
haven't been for decades if they made
fun of what culture would be the most
watched thing on broadcast TV we we have
had requests of doing uh like sketch
comedy stuff
so he could certainly start doing stuff
like that that'd be fun I think that'd
be a great idea because there's like
low-hanging fruit everywhere with I mean
Ryan long nails it yep he he Nails it
consistently we should totally be doing
similar stuff
check out Ryan long check out have you
seen Kyle Dunn again yeah he's great
with us with the Star Trek
um what are what are those episodes
called uh blarp Trek no I think a boat
uh yeah there you go and then it's uh
they were originally called something
else but you can't it's not it's not
good for the show yeah he also does the
best buying impression I've ever seen
and there's a quick skit where uh Biden
sees himself in the mirror and it
confuses him
see that skit yeah Kyle dunnigan's Genie
I I think you know we've got we've got a
couple shows in the works that are like
tentative but I think we should start
doing sketches even if we just start
with like once a week and then and then
get something rolling that would be
hilarious even if they're not that good
I mean we used to do them back in the
day right they were not good but they
were funny actually we're good they were
good uh they were like just like
amateurally produced but it was funny
when Luke was vomiting yeah and then in
the bathroom farting his brains out like
we had a lot of fun with that that was
great we did a couple of those yeah we
did we did another one that never aired
when we were testing less lethal
Munitions uh on each other well that
wasn't a skit though that was just us
getting tear gas in a garage yeah yeah
that was pretty funny though
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends and uh we should have an episode
of The Green Room in the member section
so if you go to timcast.com and you
click members only you'll now actually
start seeing different shows emerging
because we want to we want to be better
than Netflix we are going to build an
independent streaming service we've got
Tales from the inverted world just
getting the ball rolling on this one
guys the next episode's coming up Sunday
morning is a true cry mystery about the
Irish mafia in a murder so cool we've
also got Shane the the the host and the
writer he's going down to Georgia
looking up old confederate Civil War
ghost stories trying to track down old
Confederate gold and all these crazy
stories are going to be awesome and
we're gonna have a huge Arc of these
creepy it's just gonna be fantastic and
we're gonna have members only content
from that exploring the stories around
it and having these conversations
so we're definitely trying to do a lot
right now it's it's like podcast It's
relatively low budget to produce it is
kind of expensive to bring out guests
but we don't need a million dollars to
make an episode like you know A Game of
Thrones which required I think was like
4 million or something so was it four
million four to ten four to ten so we
don't have that
but there are a lot of shows that we
really do want to do so maybe we'll get
to that point if we get more and more
members we'll be able to fund our own
shows and then just think in five years
of a big library of content we'll have
comics and books and music and it'll all
just tell these weird woke you know
losers to like screw off we're doing our
own thing so thank you all for
supporting the show again smash that
like button you can follow the show at
timcast IRL but not on Tick Tock where
we're banned you can follow me at
timcast everywhere else uh do you want
to shout out anything uh shout anything
out Gary ah you can find me on YouTube
at uh nerd Roddick I do a Friday night
show that you can watch right before you
tune into timcast IRL called Friday
night tights that I do with geeks and
Gamers and heal versus Babyface and uh
quarter black Garrett is there okay so
check it out thanks for having me if you
want to support me you can on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com or Lucan
censored.com uh either way I have a lot
of fun here I have a lot of things I
want to say and I'm still censoring
myself just so you know remember that
you can put a Captain America costume on
a donkey and call it Captain America but
it doesn't make it Captain America right
that's right that's absolutely happy to
be here everyone check me out at Ian
crossland.net in True Rewards I've never
been smoking oh thank you very true
agreed yeah for sure thank you guys for
tuning in for this nerdy Friday night I
feel like we hit the balance between
news and nerdiness just right hopefully
you guys enjoyed it you guys may follow
me on Twitter at sour patchkids and on
Instagram at real Sour Patch Lids thanks
for hanging out everybody also check out
youtube.com cast Castle all of our
episodes have a funny little animated
skit you you gotta see them and what do
you remember what the episode was called
where you find the Alex Jones mushroom
because that's like the best one ever
not offhand but it was last week you
guys got to watch it until you find it
because it's a it's a cartoon of Ian
finding the screaming Alex Jones
mushroom and it's really really funny so
thanks for hanging out everybody and
we'll see y'all next time bye guys